INCLUDED ISSUES RELATING TO
EMERGENCY ALERTS WHICH WE'VE
DISCUSSED HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE BEFORE EVACUATION AND
EMERGENCY RESPONSE AND SO LAYS
COMMEND THEM FOR THAT WORK AND
WELCOME TO TESTIFY- FIRE CHIEF
DARRYL OSBY. FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY VENTURA COUNTY FIRE
CHIEF MARK LORENZEN AND CAPTAIN
DAVE GELATI- WHO IS WITH LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FIRE AS WELL AND
ALL THREE HAVE EXPERIENCE- WITH
WOLSEY SO DOMINANT I BELIEVE
CHIEF LAWRENCE AND YOU WERE
GOING TO BE SPEAKING FIRST.
THIS BUT.
OKAY PERFECT. AS AT
PERFECT. THANK YOU THAT CHAIR
AND A VICE CHAIR. HI WE ALL
APPRECIATE YOU INVITING US HERE
TO SHARE SOME OF OUR
EXPERIENCES MY NAME FOR THE
RECORD IS MARK LAWRENSON I AM
THAT VENTURA COUNTY FIRE CHIEF
I'VE BEEN WITH THE ORGANIZATION
FOR TWENTY NINE YEARS THE LAST
EIGHT. AS FIRE CHIEF. ADVENTURE
COUNTY AS YOU ALL KNOW HAS HAD
MORE THAN ITS FAIR SHARE OF
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS IN RECENT
MEMORY. THE FIRST ONE AS WE ALL
RECALL WAS THE THOMAS FIRE THAT
OCCURRED ON DECEMBER FOURTH TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FOR A BRIEF
MOMENT SIX FLEETING MONTHS IT
WAS THE LARGEST FIRE IN STATE
HISTORY- AND IT WAS ABSOLUTELY
CATASTROPHIC AS FAR AS THE
OUTCOME. AS A RESULT OF THAT. I
WAS UP HERE TWO YEARS AGO
TESTIFYING BEFORE YOUR
COMMITTEE AND WE WERE HERE
ASKING ACTUALLY SHARING SOME
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES MYSELF IN
CHIEF KOSTER BOTH AS WELL AS
OTHERS. AND WE ARE ALSO ASKING
AS PART OF THE DEAREST
COALITION FOR MONIES FOR PRE
POSITIONING WHICH YEAR-
GOVERNING BODIES ALL APPROVED
THANK GOODNESS. DID NOT EXPECT
ME BACK TODAY I THOUGHT FIRES
ARE SIGNIFICANT FIRES IN
VENTURA COUNTY WERE THROUGH BUT
OBVIOUSLY THEY WERE NOT. WHAT
HAPPENED NEXT ELEVEN MONTHS
AFTER THE THOMAS FIRE WAS
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING FOR A
COMMUNITY ON THE EVENING OF
NOVEMBER SEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND ELEVEN TWENTY PM.
WE HAD THE BORDERLINE MASS
SHOOTING WE LOST TWELVE LIVES
IN INCLUDED IN THAT IS OUR
BROTHER SERGEANT RON HERE THIS
WITH THE VENTURA COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. THE NEXT
MORNING WE ALL GATHERED UP AT
LOS ROBLES REGIONAL HOSPITAL TO
ACTUALLY HAVE A PROCESSION TO
ESCORT HIS BODY TO THE
CORONER'S OFFICE. THAT WAS AT
TEN AM AND AS WE ARE ALL LINED
UP WE COULD FEEL IT IT'S A
STARTING THE SANTA ANAS WERE
STARTING TO BLOW. FOUR HOURS
LATER. IT HAPPENED IT WAS THAT
THE START OF THE HELL FIRE AND
I WILL SAY JUST ON A PERSONAL
NOTE I'VE NEVER IN MY ENTIRE
CAREER BEEN ANGRY AT A FIRE
THIS IS MY FIRST FIRE RIGHT
EVER ACTUALLY HAD ANGER
TOWARDS. BECAUSE WE WEREN'T
READY WE WEREN'T READY AND THE
RESPECT THAT WE WERE STILL
TRYING TO HEAL FROM JUST THE
EVENTS THE NIGHT BEFORE. AND
THEN JUST TWENTY MEN TWENTY ONE
MINUTES LATER THE WAS THE FIRE
STARTED. PRIOR TO THAT WE KNEW
WE HAD SOME SIGNIFICANT WEATHER
EVENTS OCCURRING AND THIS IS
BEEN A RECURRING THEME WITH US
THAT THINGS ARE DIFFERENT AND
THAT THE PAST IS NOT THE
PRESENT. THIS FIRE WEATHER WAS
WE HAD ANTICIPATED AND PREPARED
AND WE PRE POSITIONED-
AUGMENTED OUR RESOURCES AGAIN
LIKE WE HAD DONE IN THE THOMAS
FIRE. AND COMPARED TO OUR DAILY
STAFFING WE ARE ACTUALLY 80%
ABOVE OUR REGULAR DAILY
STAFFING. THE NICE THING IN THE
THANKFUL THING WITH THIS IS IT
WASN'T JUST US NOW IT WAS. A
NUMBER OF SURROUNDING
JURISDICTION JURISDICTIONS THEY
WERE ABLE THESE A PRE
POSITIONING MONIES AND STAND UP
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. SO
INITIALLY. THE HELLFIRE
APPEARED TO BE THE GREATEST
THREAT WHEN IT FIRST STARTED IT
WAS MOVING RAPIDLY IT HAD
JUMPED THE ONE ONE FREEWAY IN A
MATTER OF FIFTEEN MINUTES WE
HAD CLOSED DOWN THE ONE ONE
FREEWAY WE ACTUALLY HAVE PEOPLE
TRAPPED IN CARS ON THE FREEWAY.
AND THEN AT A POINT LATER ON IN
THE AFTERNOON IT BECAME
APPARENT THAT THE WALLS THE
FIRE WAS NOW GOING TO EXCEED
THE THREAT CAUSED BY THE HELL
FIRE AND WE SHIFTED RESOURCES
FROM THAT. YEAH THE HELLFIRE
OVER TO THE WALLS A- THAT FIRE
THE WILL THE FIRE WENT ON TO
RAMPAGE THROUGH OAK PARK IN
BELL CANYON AND INTO THOUSAND
OAKS ACROSS THE WESTLAKE
VILLAGE AND THEN WENT ON ITS
WAY. TO AGORA IN DOWN TO MALIBU
AND- THE IMPACTS WERE
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING. ALMOST
NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND ACRES.
OVER SIXTEEN HUNDRED STRUCTURES
WERE DESTROYED FIFTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO FIGHT THE
FIRE. N THREE TO FIVE BILLION
IN UNINSURED I'M SORRY IN
INSURED LOSSES THAT DOESN'T
EVEN RECOGNIZE THE UNINSURED
LOSSES. AND SO WE HAVE SOME
CHALLENGES AND ONE OF THEM MAN
I JUST WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
IT NEWS WE'VE WE'VE HAD THESE
CHALLENGES IN THE PAST WE FOUND
WAYS TO WORK AROUND ONE IS THAT
THE RESOURCE ORDERING SYSTEM
COMMONLY KNOWN AS ROSS. IT'S
GONNA BE REPLACED IN MARCH BY
IROC OUR HOPE IS THAT THIS NEW
ARE MORE ADVANCED- ORDERING
SYSTEM WILL BE STREAMLINED AND
HELP US WITH SOME OF THE SPEED.
OF ORDERING. THERE'S CHALLENGES
IN THE FIRST TWELVE TO TWENTY
FOUR HOURS WITH OUR CURRENT
ORDERING SYSTEM. AND MY GUESS
IS THERE'S BY ALWAYS GONNA BE
SOME CHALLENGES. OUR INITIAL
COMMITMENT WITH IN OUR COUNTY
WAS TWENTY TWO ENGINES THAT'S
ALMOST HALF OF THE ENGINES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE COUNTY WHY THAT
WAS THE INITIAL COMMITMENT
ONTO. THE TWO FIRES WITHIN THE
FIRST HOUR. WE ORDERED ONE
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL ENGINES OR
TWENTY STRIKE TEAMS AS WE OFTEN
REFER TO- WHICH IS FIVE ENGINES
AND A BATTALION CHIEF. AN HOUR
AND FORTY FIVE MINUTES LATER WE
WERE INFORMED. THAT OF THE
HUNDRED ENGINES THAT WE HAD
ORDERED THIRTY OF THEM WERE
CURRENTLY IN ROUTE. AND THIS IS
WHERE WE ALWAYS STRUGGLING HAVE
CHALLENGES BUT WE RECOGNIZE
THIS UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE HAD SO
MUCH EXPERIENCE IN PRACTICE
THAT WE DON'T JUST SIT AND WAIT
FOR THE SYSTEM TO WORK. WE WORK
AROUND IT. AND SO WHAT WE DO
AND I TESTED TESTIFIED TO THIS
TWO YEARS AGO IF WE START
MAKING PHONE CALLS TO LOCAL
ADJACENT JURISDICTIONS I CALL
CHIEF OZ BE. IN LA COUNTY CHIEF
TO RAZA CINELLI CITY AN ORANGE
COUNTY FIRE CHIEF IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY. AND WHAT I
EXPLAINED WE HAVE THIS LEVEL OF
TRUST IS THAT I HAVE AN
IMMINENT THREAT. HAVE IMMEDIATE
LOSS OF LIFE AND PROPERTY.
WHATEVER YOU CAN SEND SEND IT
QUICKLY AND THEY DO. THEY WILL
STRETCH BEYOND WHAT THE NORM
NORMALLY MAKE AVAILABLE FOR THE
STATE WIDE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
BECAUSE IT'S A NEIGHBOR IN
IMMEDIATE NEED. AND WE ALSO
HAVE THIS UNDERSTANDING THAT
WHEN THAT. IMMEDIATE NEED.
SUBSIST SO LITTLE BIT WE WILL
RETURN THOSE RESOURCES TO THEM
SO. IT IT ALLOWS US TO GO IN
AND MAKE AN INCREDIBLY
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT. SO I THINK
THE THING TO RECOGNIZE IS THAT
EVEN IF WE MAKE ROSS- IROC
PERFECT IN THE FUTURE WE ARE
NEVER GOING TO ALLEVIATE THE
NEED FOR THIS SURGE FROM
ADJACENT RESOURCES THAT'S JUST
GOING TO BE SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE ALWAYS GOING TO NEED TO
DO. TO THAT END. HELLO YES IN
THE FIRES GO BOARD HAS PUT
TOGETHER A PILOT PROGRAM. IT'S
CALLED EXPEDITED RESOURCE
RESPONSE OR E. R. R. IT'S A
IT'S A PILOT PROGRAM BETWEEN.
VENTURA LA COUNTY LA CITY
ORANGE COUNTY IN IT WHAT IT
DOES IS IT MEMORIALIZES EXACTLY
WHAT WE DO AND I THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY WHAT WE'RE GONNA NEED
FOR THE FUTURE IS JUST TO SAY
OUT LOUD. THAT THE SYSTEM IS A
COMPLEX SYSTEM AND THERE'S
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT THINGS ARE
GONNA MAKE A SUCCESSFUL AND
HAVING THOSE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE THAT
RELATIONSHIP WHERE WE CAN.
SQUEEZE RESOURCES INTO ONE
AGENCY AND GET THEM BACK. IS
GOING TO MAKE THIS THE SYSTEM
PARTIALLY SUCCESSFUL. SO THE
CHALLENGES WITH THE WALLS THE
FIRE. ONE OF THE BIG CHALLENGES
WAS OBVIOUSLY TWENTY MINUTES
PRIOR WE HAD THE HELL FIRE AND
A SIGNIFICANT RESOURCE NEED
THERE WE WERE COMPETING WITH
THE CAMP FIRE THAT HAD STARTED
EARLIER THAT MORNING. THIS IS
VERY DIFFERENT THAN THOMAS FIRE
WHERE WE WERE PRETTY MUCH THE
ONLY FIRE IN THE STATE AND WE
PROBABLY ENDED UP RECEIVING
TWICE AS MANY RESOURCES AS WE
DID ON THE WALLS THE FIRE. SO
ONE THING TO NOTICE THAT OUR
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM IN THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE IN IT WILL
NEVER BE ENOUGH AND AS I
ATTENDED COMMUNITY MEETINGS AND
WE HAD A LOT OF UNDERSTANDABLY
UPSET CONSTITUENTS AND
HOMEOWNERS WHO LOST THEIR HOMES
IS THE CONSISTENT MESSAGE WAS
THERE WASN'T ENOUGH RESOURCES
THERE WEREN'T ENGINES IN MY
HEAD NEIGHBORHOOD THERE WEREN'T
ENGINES AT MY HOUSE AND- I
THINK BY THE MOST POWERFUL
THING WAS JUST TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT. THIS EIGHT YOU'RE RIGHT
THERE WEREN'T AND THERE
PROBABLY NEVER WILL BE. AND
WHAT WE DO THOUGH IS WHAT WE
TAKE THAT THE LIMITED RESOURCES
WE HAVE BEEN WILL TRIAGE HE
SITUATION WE PUT THEM WHERE
THEY CAN DO THE VERY MOST GOOD
AND WE TRY AND DO THE BEST WE
CAN WITH THE RESOURCES WE HAVE.
YEAH IF WE HAD HAD DOUBLE THE
RESOURCES WE STILL WOULD HAVE
HAD SIGNIFICANT LOSSES. SO ONE
OF THE SOLUTIONS ALSO THAT WE
NEED TO DO AS WE GO FORWARD IS
TO CHANGE THE PUBLIC'S
EXPECTATIONS. AS WE HAVE SAID
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A NEW NORMAL
OUR FIRES A SPREAD MUCH MORE
QUICKLY OUR FIRE SEASON IS YEAR
ROUND WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE
PUBLIC'S EXPECTATIONS IS AS FAR
AS- WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE IN
YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD WHEN WE HAVE
A FIRE AND WE NEED THE PUBLIC
TO PARTNER WITH US TO- IN AN
EFFORT TO BE PREPARED THAT
MEANS. IT'S DEFENSIBLE SPACE
IT'S HARDENING THEIR STRUCTURES
IN ADVANCE OF FIRE SEASON
SOMTIMES IT'S YOU KNOW JUST
CHANGING UP THE ORNAMENT
ORNAMENTAL VEGETATION SOMETIMES
IT MEANS. GOING AND- YEAH PLATE
REPLACING THEIR THEIR ATTIC
VENTS SCREEN SO IT'S A SMALLER
THING BECAUSE SO MANY OF OUR
HOMES ARE DESTROYED BY. THE
AMBER ENVIRONMENT NOT DIRECT
FLAME CONTACT. AND THEN IT'S
ALSO HAVING A PREPARED
COMMUNITY THAT PARTICIPATES IN
A WRECK SAID GO PROGRAM SO THAT
THEY ARE WELL PLANNED IN
ADVANCE. AND WHEN THEY SEE
SMOKE IN THE AIR THE PLAN IS
ALREADY IN PLACE THEY HAVE ALL
THEIR VALUABLES THEY KNOW WHERE
THEY ARE THEY CAN PLACE THEM IN
THE CAR AND AS SOON AS WORD
COMES OUT FROM. EITHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OF THE EVACUATED
DELAYED. BECAUSE WE KNOW FIRE.
WILL RISK A LITTLE TO A LITTLE
RISK LET SABLE. WHEN LIVES ARE
IN JEOPARDY WE HAVE TO RISK SO
MUCH MORE. AND THAT'S ONE OF
pSEEN I SOUGHT THE FIRST TIMEON
THE THOMAS FIRE. IS IT
TYPICALLY WHEN WE SEND OUR
ENGINES UP THERE ON NORMAL
FIRES WERE TRYING TO WORK ON
PERIMETER CONTROL TO PUT OUT
THE FIRE AND WIND DRIVEN FIRES
WE TYPICALLY GO UP AND START
STRUCTURE PROTECTION. WHAT WE
SAW ON THE THOMAS FIRE WAS THAT
OUR ENGINES DIDN'T EVEN HAVE
TIME TO PROTECT STRUCTURES THEY
WERE ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN A
LIFESAVING EVACUATIONS. ONLY
PEOPLE OUT OF THE HOMES
THROWING THEM IN OUR FIRE
ENGINES A SAME THING WAS
HAPPENING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE EXACT SAME THING HAPPENED
IN THE WALLS THE FIRE. WE HAVE
A WHOLE NEW NORMAL THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH AND A PUBLIC THAT
NEEDS TO RECOGNIZE. SOME
NOTABLE SUCCESSES. THE VALUE OF
PRE POSITIONING AS YOU WILL
HEAR AN ADDITIONAL TERROR A
TESTIMONY THAT CANNOT BE
UNDERSTATED I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE AND THANK. YOU ALL
FOR SUPPORTING THAT. NOW THAT
WE HAVE PRE POSITIONING IS
AVAILABLE FOR A JUST A WHOLE
WIDE VARIETY OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES WHAT THAT
DOES IS IT IF THEY HAVE STOOD
UP ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO SEND ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO THEIR NEIGHBORS IT
DOESN'T JUST PROTECT THEIR HOME
DIRT. IF I HAVE EIGHTY THAT
MORE RESOURCES ON I CAN SLIDE-
OUT A LOT MORE TO THE NORTH OR
THE SOUTH. BECAUSE I CAN STILL
PROTECT MY RESPONSIBILITIES AT
HOME. EN THAT SURGE THAT NEED
FOR THAT SURGE FROM NEIGHBORING
AGENCIES THAT'S NEVER GOING TO
GO AWAY WE KNOW. THAT IT'S SAVE
LIVES AND PROPERTY WITHOUT A
DOUBT. THE OTHER NOTABLE
SUCCESSES THAT OVER A QUARTER
MILLION PEOPLE WERE EVACUATED
AND SAFELY EVACUATED THERE ARE
STILL SOME LOSS OF LIFE BUT IT
JUST AGAIN IN THIS MY FINAL
COMMENT HAS TO DO WITH. THE
INTERACTION IN COORDINATION.
WITH NEIGHBORING COUNTIES AND
ALSO WITH- NEIGHBORING GENCIES
AND INTERNAL AGENCIES AND JUST
THE SUCCESS RELATED TO THAT.
THAT CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY
I'LL BE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
LATER. THANK YOU TO CHIEF I
THINK THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON-
MY NAME IS THERE US BEYOND THE
FIRE CHIEF. OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT SO.
MADAM SHARES IN THE COMMITTEE
OF LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR.
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK AGAIN I
WAS HERE TWO YEARS AGO BUT THEN
I WAS SPEAKING. ABOUT HALF MY
COUNTERPARTS AS THE MUTILATE
SYSTEM BUT NOW SINCE THEN WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPERIENCE THE WOLSELEY.
INCIDENT KIND OF WANT TO THANK
MY COUNTERPART VENTURA COUNTY
BECAUSE- THE FIRE STARTED IN
HIS JURISDICTION. AND THEN
BROWN INTO THE LA COUNTY- I
THINK THAT WHEN YOU. AND SOME
OF THE THINGS I'M GONNA APPEARS
ON A GOING TO BE. REPETITIVE
BUT BECAUSE THEY'RE IMPORTANT.
AND ALSO I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE YOUR COMMITTEE REPORT
BUT I'M GOING TO. REPEAT SOME
THINGS OUT OF THERE BECAUSE
THEY'RE IMPORTANT- I DO HAVE A
COPY THE WHEELS THE REPORT BUT-
THE TIME THAT. WAS GIVEN TO US
OF THE PERMIT ME TO GO THROUGH
ALL THE- THE POINTS. I THINK
THAT HOW MANY READ THESE
REPORTS AND YOU LISTEN TO WAS
SPEAK I THINK THERE IS A PEACE
IS WILLIAM MISSING AND I'M
MAYBE MY UNION PRESENT WILL
SPEAK TO THAT A PREFIX AFTER I
SPEAK IS THE IMPACT IT HAS ON
PEOPLE. THE IMPACT IT HAS ON
OUR FIREFIGHTERS. I'M EVEN
DOING THE WILL THE FIRE I TO
TAKE A TIME OUT AND CALL. MY
COUNTERPARTS DIFFERENCE IN JUST
ASK HOW DO I MANAGE HIS BECAUSE
FORTUNATELY FOR ME. HE DON'T
THE THOMAS FIRE BEFORE AND SO.
I WAS JUST OVERWHELMING TO
THINK THAT WE WERE DOING
SOMETHING THAT EXCEEDED THE
CAPACITY OF OUR ORGANIZATION.
AND IT'S HARD TO CAPTURE THAT.
I'M EVEN WITH OUR UNION
PRESIDENT WHEN WE ARE ASKING
FOR MUTUAL AID. AND WE DIDN'T
GET ENOUGH FR ME TO PLAY. THE
REPORT SAYS THAT AT THE END OF
THE DAY 53% OF REQUEST ON
FIELD. BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT
CRITICAL TIMES OF THE FIRE. WAS
OVER SEVENTY PERCENT. BECAUSE
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BEGINNING
OF OUR FIRE WERE BEGAN A
VENTURA COUNTY. BY THE TIME WE
GOT TO THE SAID THE GOSHEN IT
WAS LIKE EIGHTEEN HOURS. THOSE
OVER 90% OF THE FIRE HAPPENED
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS. SO
WHAT KIND OF MILK MUTUALLY
RESOURCES FUNNY CAME. WHEN THEY
DID COME AND IT WASN'T ENOUGH
OF THEM. AS SOME FROM OUT OF
STATE. SEVERAL DAYS LATER THE
HELP THIS MONTH THE FIRE UP
BUT- FOR THE MOST PART. WHAT
WAS GONNA HAPPEN HAPPENED- BUT
WAS HARD TO. ARTICULATE AS FAR
FAR FAR TO ASKING FOR HELP IN A
SCREAM FOR HELP THEY CAN'T GET
IT. WAS HARD TO ARTICULATE IS
WHEN YOU CAN'T PROVIDE ENOUGH
ASSISTANCE AND I'M GOING TO
BUY. UNION PRESIDENT TO
MADHAPAR IMHO YOU TO SAY WE
CAN'T DO THE WORK RIGHT CYCLE
WHICH IS NORMALLY. A TWELVE ARE
CYCLE THE FIRST FORTY EIGHT
HOURS OF OUR INCIDENT. OUR
FOREFATHERS WROTE. WAS FROM. ME
TOWARDS WHEN A WORKER THAT NO
ONE GOT SLEEP. AT THE SAME TIME
WE HAVE TO TAKE IN
CONSIDERATION THAT AND A MAJOR
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS MINE WE
SO GET OVER A THOUSAND OTHER
CALLS A DAY THAT DON'T GO AWAY.
AND DURING THE FOOTPRINT OF THE
WHEELS THE FIRE ANOTHER
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED MEDICAL
EMERGENCY CALLS CAME IN BECAUSE
OF PEOPLE TRAPPED OR NOT
KNOWING WHAT TO DO SO THOSE ARE
SOME SALIENT RIO. BEHAVIORAL
MENTAL STRESSFUL THINGS ARE FAR
FAR AS GO THROUGH. AND THEN THE
AFTERMATH FROM ANY FIRE CHIEF
IN THIS ROOM. IS REALLY GO OUT
TO A COMMUNITY EXPLAIN WHY WE
LOST HER HOME. AND I THINK THAT
WE ALL SYMPATHETIC AND LISTEN
TO SOMEONE LOSE THEIR HOME AND
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT FEELS
LIKE. BUT IS NOT A GOOD FEELING
TO EXPLAIN IT TO SOMEONE OR FAR
FAR FORCES AT WORK IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. AND GET SOME OF
THE RAF OF A TWO FOUR- THEIR
INABILITY TO PROTECT ALL THE
HOMES WHEN IT WASN'T THEIR
FAULT. BECAUSE WE CANNOT
PROVIDE ENOUGH RESOURCES. I
AGREE WITH CHIEF RUNS IN. A WE
WOULD NEVER HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES BUT WE NEED MORE WAS
WORTH MENTIONING THAT WAS THE
FIRE. WAS THAT WE DID
SUCCESSFULLY EVACUATE OVER
TWENTY FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE. AND WE DID HAVE TO
PRIORITIZE WE MADE A PROP A
PRIORITY TO FOCUS ON LIFE
FIRST. AND ALL THE EXIT
CORRIDORS WHEN IT JUMP TO ONE
ONE FREEWAY THE ONLY EXIT
QUARTER LEFT WAS PCH SO THE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN. LA
COUNTY VENTURA CH P. SHERIFF
WAS AND THE CITIZENS WAS
REMARKABLE. AND AT THE SAME
TIME OUR FIREFIGHTERS BECAUSE
WHEN I HAD TO EXPLAIN TO MY
GOVERNING BODY. WHICH WAS NOT
OTHER EASY THING TO DO. WHY WE
LOST OVER SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOMES.
IS THAT I TOLD THEM WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES TO DO
EVERYTHING SO WE FOCUSED ON
LIFE. AT THE EXPENSE OF
KNOWINGLY LOSING STRUCTURES. SO
ANY ADDITIONAL APPARATUS THAT
WE CAN GET THROUGH STORAGE
COULD HAVE SAVED THAT MANY MORE
STRUCTURES. WAS WAS MENTIONED
IN THE REPORT AND- I KNOW THE
TOW BAR MAYBE HERE- YES MAY BE
BEHIND ME I DON'T KNOW IF THE-
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S GONNA
SPEAK IS THAT. ON THE RULES LEE
FIRE. ARM MOST OF THE- PUT
PRINT WAS NOT LOCAL
RESPONSIBILITY. OVER 40% I WAS
THE DIVISION WAS STATE
RESPONSIBILITY PLANS OTHER WE
HAVE A CONTRACT WITH THEM AND
OVER 20% WITH FEDERAL
RESPONSIBLE SO THERE'S A HUGE
IMPACT ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PROVIDE RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROTECTION SERVICES FOR AREAS
THE FALL WITHOUT SORT OF SUMMER
JURISDICTION BECOMES OUT OF OUR
BUDGETS. AND AT THE SAME TIME
WE LOOK AT THE MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM DEPENDING WHERE YOU ARE
AND THE STATE 7080% OF THE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM WAS CONDUCTED
BY LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHICH IS A
HUGE IMPACT I KNOW WE'RE NOT
HERE TO TALK ABOUT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BUDGET BUT I CAN IT
NOT EVEN BEGIN TO TELL YOU. THE
IMPACT HAS A MY BUDGET. IN
RELATION TO TRYING TO. PROVIDE
FIRE PROTECTION SERVICES TO
THE- THOSE THE COUNTY. WE HAVE
A ROOM WITH CAL FIREBIRD IS NOT
REIMBURSE IS TO THE KNEADED
NEEDS TO BE REIMBURSED. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION AND THEN THE
THOUGHT AN IDEA THAT WE COULD
POTENTIALLY. TO MUTILATE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT- MIGHT NOT GET
REIMBURSED. WE DID I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THAT- BUT IT'S A HUGE
PART OF TIMES MY ORGANIZATION-
I WILL CONCLUDE. ARM MY
COMMENTS BECAUSE MOST OF THEM
WERE SAID BY CHEAPER RUN TO AND
THEN READ THE REPORT. ON THAT
FOR A LATER CONSTRUCTION WE DO
HAVE A AFTER ACTION REVIEW THAT
UNDER EMPLOYMENT IN THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES. I WAS REGARD
FAR APART. A LOT OF IT IN
RELATION TO- PUBLIC EDUCATION
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE DID
IS THAT. WE REALLY DID A BETTER
READY SET GO PROGRAM TO REALLY.
GIVE OUR SERVICE MORE PICTURES
AND MORE DESCRIPTION. ABOUT
EVERYTHING THAT THEY NEED TO DO
TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROTECT THE HOME. AND ADVANCE
OF A MAJOR AIR. IN AFTER THE
INCIDENT TO NOT WAIT FOR THE
EVACUATION ORDER TO LEAVE
EARLY. ONE OF THE CHOICES THAT
WE DID FIND AS WITH THE
EVACUATION. WHEN THERE'S A OR
OUT. IT'S KIND OF HARD TO GET
MESSAGE OUT. SO PHONES DON'T
WORK YOUR BONES DON'T WORK
RADIOS DON'T WORK TV IS NOT
WORKING IN SOME INSTANCES AS
ANOTHER CONVERSATION BUT WE
HAVE MULTIPLE. OF WATER
PURVEYORS INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA
DON'T HAVE WATER OR POWER THE
MERSEY BACKUP. SO IN MANY
INSTANCES ARE FIREFIGHTERS IN
SITUATIONS WHEN THE POWER GOES
UP THEY DON'T HAVE WATER WHICH
IS THE FIREFIGHTERS BEST FRIEND
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF COMPLEX
ISSUES THAT WE WERE ALSO.
DEALING WITH IN RELATION TO
THIS AND TO THE- BUT I WILL
CONCLUDE WITH THIS IS THAT.
WERE APPRECIATIVE OF YUBA THE
PRE POSITIONING UNITS TO HELP
WE WERE ABLE TO ALLOCATE THOSE
OVER TO THE HELLFIRE- WE DO
HAVE AN OUTSTANDING
RELATIONSHIP SO WHEN THE FIRED
THE BEGINNING VENTURA COUNTY
RESOURCES MY DEPARTMENT AND THE
EARLY CITY WERE IN VENTURA
COUNTY HELPING THEM WITH THE
WILL BE FAR WHEN IT BEGAN- THE
REPORT DOES SAY ONE THING. WE
DO WE NEED MORE RESOURCES. BRAD
AS WE NEED MORE AIRCRAFT WE
MEET BETTER COMMUNICATION
SYSTEMS WHEN. I MY ORGANIZATION
WHEN I SAY WE PUT ALL OF OUR
RESOURCES AT BAY. WE WENT ON
RESOURCES WE STILL HAVE FAR FAR
AS IT WENT TO WORK. SO I CAN
ONLY SUPPLY SO MANY APPARATUS
MY ORGANIZATION BUT THERE'S A
COLLABORATIVE BETWEEN THE STATE
AND THE FEDERAL ENTITIES IN
RELATION TO IF THEY CAN'T. HELP
US WITH MUTUALLY SYSTEM AT
LEAST HAVE CACHES OF EQUIPMENT.
THAT THEY CAN HAVE STAGED AND
MUNICIPALITY SUCH AS OURS I'M
SURE THERE'S OTHER EXAMPLES
THERE YOU HAVE FIREFIGHTERS
COMING TO WORK THAT WANT TO
WORK. BUT THE MUNICIPALITY
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO THEM. WE
NEED TO TALK ABOUT THAT FURTHER
SO I WANT TO TAKE UP TOO MUCH
MORE TIME I KNOW MY-
COUNTERPARTS APPEARS HELPING TO
SAY BUYS ONCE AGAIN. INCLUDES
IS REALLY THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO US TODAY IN YOUR
COMMITMENT TOWARD THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU CHIEF. CAPTAIN
READING. WHEN I HEAR THE WORDS
CAPTAINS SO MANY CHIEFS IN THE
ROOM I THINK I'M IN TROUBLE. MY
NAME IS DAVE GELATI AND- A FIRE
CAPTAIN AT THE LA COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT. THIS IS MY THIRTY
SECOND YEAR AS A PAID
PROFESSIONAL FIRE FIGHTER. OF
HELL THE RANKS OF PARAMEDIC.
FIREFIGHTERS ENGINEER AND
CAPTAIN I ALSO WHERE ANOTHER
HOT HERE TODAY ON THE UNION
PRESIDENT OF THE LA COUNTY
FIREFIGHTERS- UNION LOCAL TEN
FOURTEEN AND IFF LOCAL I'M
REPRESENTING A BRIAN RICE WHO
HEADS UP THE STATE UNION AND I
SIT ON THAT BOARD. OF BEEN ON
THAT BOARD FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS
HAVING SAID THAT I ALSO WORK
FOR DURALAST BE SO I CAME IN
WITH MY BUSTED. I WE DO HAVE
TRUE COLLABORATION- BETWEEN
LABOR AND MANAGEMENT AS YOU
WILL SEE THAT THE SPIRIT OF.
WITH IN A STATE ORDERING SYSTEM
THAT IS CUMBERSOME BUT IS
PROBLEMATIC IF YOU LET JUST THE
SYSTEM ITSELF. BE USED TO ORDER
RESOURCES AND SHARE RESOURCES
WE HAVE TO HAVE THE HUMAN
ELEMENT. OF THE FIRE CHIEFS THE
UNION PRESIDENTS THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE OUT DOING THE WORK
THAT THEY REPRESENT- EMBEDDED
IN THAT SYSTEM AS WELL. I TO
THINK THROUGH SOME OF THE
DECISIONS WHEN WE'RE SHORT
STAFFED. YOU CAN HEAR A LOT OF
STATISTICS TODAY AND I WANT TO
THANK MY STAFF TO GIVE ME A TON
OF POINTS TO TALK ABOUT HERE
AND I'M NOT GONNA USE ANY OF
THEM THE- IT. THE MY MOTHER. MY
AND SPRAY. ONCE YOU TO. TAKE A
MINUTE AND A- WHAT I'M ABOUT TO
TELL YOU. AS A LINE DUTY FIRE
CAPTAIN I WORK IT FOR STATION
SIXTEEN AN ALLY IT'S IN THE
WATTS WILLOWBROOK AREA. UNDER
A- RESOURCE STEREO OF LA
COUNTY. I HAVE TWO ENGINES
THERE AND PARAMEDICS WATTAGE
AND SIXTEEN ENGINE NINE AND
PARAMEDICS WHAT SIXTEEN. SO
WELL READ STATION I'M AN ENGINE
NINE IT'S WHAT'S CALLED US.
TEAM GEN. AND FOR ALL OF OUR
AGENCIES WE HAVE. UNITS THAT
ARE PRE DESIGNATED A STRIKE
TEAM ENGINES DURING THE
WILDFIRE SEASON WHICH IS ALL
YOU'RE NOT. AS A CAPTAIN I COME
IN IN THE MORNINGS AND A
SPECIAL. AS YOU WERE SAYING YOU
WHEN WE FELT THE WIND CHANGE IN
THE MORNING AND WE WERE JUST
COMINGOFF OF THE BORDERLINE
SHOOTING. WICH AFFECTED LA
COUNTY FIREFIGHTERS WHO LIVE IN
THAT AREA WHOSE KIDS WERE AT
THAT NIGHT CLUB THAT NIGHT
THINKING WHAT ELSE CAN POSSIBLY
HAPPEN. AT SIX THIRTY IN THE
MORNING TELL YOU WHAT HAPPENED.
THE CAMP FIRE IGNITED AND AS WE
WERE BUSY WATCHING THAT ON TV
THINKING HOLY SMOKES. I HOPE WE
DON'T GET A FIRE DOWN HERE AND
OF COURSE. THE HELL FIRE
STARTED AND SHORTLY THEREAFTER
THE WE'LL SEE FIRE. I WAS ON
THAT STREET TO MENTION. THEM
ALL OF OUR CREWS WERE
DISPATCHED OUT TO PREPARE FOR
THE WILL THE FIRE WE HAD NO
IDEA HOW BIG THAT FIRE WAS
GOING TO GROW. WE THOUGHT WE
HAD ENOUGH RESOURCES WE GOT IN
PLACE. ON THE INTERIOR SIDE OF
THE ONE ONE FREEWAY YOU BOTH
KNOW THAT FREEWAY. YEAH YOU
THINK YOURSELF IT'S NOT GOING
TO JUMP THE ONE ONE FREEWAY AND
GO ALL THE WAY TO THE OCEAN IS
IT AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO MAKE OUR- AND- WE HAD ALL
OUR RESOURCES. POSITIONED AND
EVERYBODY WAS IN ACTIVE
FIREFIGHT. THERE WAS FIRE
EVERYWHERE AND LET ME GIVE YOU
A PERSPECTIVE ON THAT. AT THE
PEAK FIRE. JUST PICTURE CITY
BLOCK IN SACRAMENTO. PICTURE A
FIRE RAGED. WITH EIGHTY TWO
HUNDRED MILE AN HOUR WINDS
DRIVING IT TOWARDS THE OCEAN.
PICTURE THAT FIRE BEING THIRD
TEAM MILES LONG. THIRTEEN MILES
WIDE AND A BUNCH OF TINY HUMANS
MEN AND WOMEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
HUMANS IN THE WAY THAT FIRE
TRYING TO HOLD BACK A THIRTEEN
MILE WIDE FIRE FRONT. IT IS
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE AND WE SAW
IT JUMPED THE ONE ONE FREEWAY.
I'LL NEVER FORGET WHAT I HEARD
ON THE RADIO. WE HAD ONE OF
OUR- WILDLAND FIRE EXPERT
SUPERVISORS WHO WORKED IN THE
CAMPS AS A FOREMAN HE WORKED ON
THE ENGINES PROMOTED THROUGH
THE RANKS. I'LL NEVER FORGET HE
KEEP THE MIKE. AND I HEARD THE
FOLLOWING WORDS. LA AND THAT'S
OUR DISPATCH CENTER. AND I'M
GONNA BRING TO LIGHT WITH THE
DISPATCHERS WENT THROUGH AS
WELL. LA DIVISION GROUP SOUP
WHATEVER'S TITLE WAS ON THE
FIRE THAT THEIR DIVISION GROUP
SOUP. WE HAVE FIRE THAT IS
CROSS THE ONE O. ONE. AND IS
GOING TO GO ALL THE WAY TO THE
OCEAN I NEED AND THERE WAS A
PAUSE AND HE SAID THE WORDS. I
NEED FIFTY STRIKE TEAMS. FOR
THOSE F US IN THE BUSINESS WE
LOOKED AT EACH OTHER IN THE
MIDDLE OF FIGHTING FIRE AND
SAID. WHAT DID YOU JUST SAY.
THE TRIED ORDER FIFTY STRIKE
TEAMS. NOBODY ORDERS FIFTY
STRIKE TEAMS YOU CAN'T GET IT.
IF YOU ORDER TO STRIKE TEAMS
AND A STRIKE TEAM IS FIVE
ENGINES WITH THE SUPERVISOR. SO
TO STRIKE SEEMS TO BE TENANTS
AS HE ORDERED FIFTY STRIKE
TEAMS. AND EVERYBODY THOUGHT HE
HAD LOST HIS MIND. LATER WHEN I
TALK TO ME SAID I COULDN'T
THINK OF WHAT ELSE TO SAY.
OTHER THAN TWO ORDERS SO MANY
STRIKE TEAMS BUT I WOULD CATCH
EVERYBODY'S ATTENTION ON THE
RADIO AND HOPEFULLY SOMEBODY IN
THE DECISION MAKING ROOMS
ATTENTION TO SAY WE NEED
RESOURCES. BOTTOM LINE WE
COULDN'T GET THEM. WE HAD
NEIGHBORHOODS BURNING. AS WE
WERE PULLING PEOPLE FROM THEIR
HOMES WE WERE NOT TRYING TO PUT
THE FIRE OUT. WE WERE NOT
TRYING TO SAVE PROPERTY. WE
WERE TRYING TO SAVE LIVES.
PERIOD AND WE WERE DEALING WITH
RESIDENTS THAT THOUGHT THEY
COULD STAY BEHIND. AND DEFEND
THEIR HOMES IT ABSOLUTELY
SHOULD NOT HAPPEN. BUT WE KNEW
PEOPLE WERE TUCKED BACK IN THE
INTERSECTIONS IN THE ALLEYS OF
THE HILLS. EMBEDDED IN THE
HILLS OF MALIBU IN VENTURA.
PEOPLE LIVE WAY BACK IN THERE
AND THEY WEREN'T LEAVING. SUCH
A HOT HAPPENS THEY CALL OUR
DISPATCH CENTER. LAST YEAR I
GOT TO BRING A COUPLE OF MY
DISPATCHES APPEARED TO TESTIFY
ON THE PUBLIC SAFETY DISPATCHER
BILL WITHIN THE TESTIMONY MY
DISPATCHER BROKE DOWN AND GOT
US ALL CRYING IN THE ROOM AND
SHE SAID I WAS TAKING CALLS.
AND LISTENING TO PEOPLE CRY.
AND SCREEN. AND ON THE OTHER
END OF THE PHONE ARE. B.
PLEADING FOR US TO SEND
RESOURCES TO HELP THEM. AND SHE
SAID I COULD SEND THEM ANYBODY.
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE RESOURCES
SHE HAD A BIG IMPACT ON ME AS
YOU CAN TO. WE SHOULDN'T BE
PUTTING OUR DISPATCH CENTERS.
OR FIREFIGHTERS OR THE CITIZENS
IN YOUR DISTRICTS IN ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS THAT WE PROTECT AND
SERVE. IN HARM'S WAY TO A POINT
WHERE WE CAN. BE EFFECTIVE IN
SAVING LIVES I'M VERY PROUD OF
THE WORK OF ALL THE MUNICIPAL
AGENCIES CAL FIRE FOR SERVICE
AND EVERYBODY IN THOSE INITIAL
STAGES OF THAT FIRE. BECAUSE TO
EVACUATE NEARLY THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE. AND GOD BLESS
YOU ONLY HAVE THREE DS WE HAD
NUMEROUS OTHER PEOPLE BURNED.
WE HAD HOMES LIVES DESTROYED WE
LOST A LOT OF PROPERTY BUT TO
MOVE THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE. AND GET HIM OUT OF THE
WAY OF THIRTEEN MILES OF FIRE.
WITH EIGHTY TWO HUNDRED MILE AN
HOUR WINDS WITHOUT THE
RESOURCES TO DO IT. WAS
REMARKABLE. SO I JUST WANTED TO
BRING TO YOU A LITTLE VISION OF
WHAT IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU'RE OUT
ON THE FIRE TODAY WHEN I GOT UP
TO COME HERE I LOOKED IN MY
LOCKER AT THE STATION I SAID I
BETTER GRAB MY UNIFORM AND I
KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE WITH ALL
THE CHIEFS THEY'RE PRETTY GOOD
LOOKING GUYS. THEY WERE ALL THE
FAT FROM ST I HAVE A- A BUT I
DECIDED TO GRAB MY BILLION FORM
TODAY IN THE PAST I HAVE ONE.
WITH PURPOSE I LOOKED AT HIM
AND I SAID OH MAN. THERE ARE.
THIS IS THE PASSED THE WAR FOR
THE FIRST THIRTY. SIX HOURS ON
THE WAS A FIRE. WHICH I
COULDN'T STAND WHERE AND MANY
MORE. AND GOT ITEM. AN
APPARTEMENT TODAY JUST TO DRIVE
SOME MOTIVATION TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT THOSE FIRST THIRTY SIX
HOURS WERE LIKE. WE HAD NO REST
WE HAD NO FOOD WE HAD NO WATER
WE WERE SELF CONTAINED AND WE
WERE GOING FROM. HOUSE TO HOUSE
FROM NEIGHBORHOOD TO
NEIGHBORHOOD. CARRYING PEOPLE
OUT ON OUR BACKS GETTING THEM
OUT OF THE NEIGHBORHOODS. AND
FOR THIRTY SIX HOURS OR MORE
THERE WAS NO RELIEF BECAUSE WE
DID NOT HAVE BODIES WE DID NOT
HAVE ENGINES WE DID NOT HAVE
RESOURCES TO ROTATE OUT. AND
EVERYBODY STAYED ON THE LINE
AND DID A GOOD JOB. ALONG THOSE
LINES LATER IN THE FIRE WHEN I
PUT ON MY UNION HAT. I GOT TO
RUN THE PEER SUPPORT TRAILER AT
THE CAMP AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE RESOURCE DOUBT.
FIREFIGHTERS WHO RAN ON THE
BORDERLINE SHOOTING IN FACT.
PACKED THEIR GEAR AND ONE ON
THE FIRE WITHOUT A MINUTE TO
GRIEVE. THEY STARTED GRIEVING
ABOUT TWO WEEKS INTO THE FIRES
AND WE HAD TO DO WITHOUT. BUT
THE FIRE CHIEF CALLED ME SAID.
WE'RE OUT OF ENGINES BUT WE GOT
BODIES. WHAT CAN WE DO AND WE
WERE THINKING ABOUT IT AND- IT
CAME TO US IN A CONVERSATION. I
THINK WE'RE OVER TIRED. I SAID
WELL THE BODIES ARE GETTING
TIRED THE ENGINES IN THE
EQUIPMENT. THEY CAN KEEP
RUNNING. WHAT IF WE LEFT
ENGINES IN PLACE AND WE PUT TWO
SHIFTS OF FIREFIGHTERS PER
ENGINE. AND WE JUST STARTED
ROTATING A MOUNTAIN CAMP WE
HAVE THREE SHIFTS ON THE
DEPARTMENT SO SENSUAL AT THAT
POINT ONE SHIFT COVERED ALL THE
AREAS THAT WE STILL HAD TO
PROTECT. IN THE LA COUNTY AREAS
SOME MASSIVE. TWO THOUSAND. WAS
IT THANK YOU IT'S A IT'S A
LARGER VOTE COUNT AND WE HAD TO
PUT OUT ONE SHIFT IN THE
STATIONS AND THEY STAYED THERE
FOR TWO WEEKS OR OR LONGER AND
THEN WE TOOK OUR OTHER TWO
SHIFTS AND WE ASSIGN THAT. AND
IF I AM THEM TO THE- TWO SHIPS
THAT'S NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE
AND OUR AGENCY AND WE WERE ABLE
TO ROTATE THE WORKERS ON TO THE
MACHINES AND BE MORE EFFECTIVE
IF WE HAD MORE PENSIONS. WE
COULD PUT THOSE FIREFIGHTERS IN
SERVICE A FEW OTHER THINGS I'M
GONNA STAY AYE ORNAMENTAL
VEGETATION ARE YOU HERE FROM
SOME FIRE PREVENTION TODAY THEY
DO AMAZING WORK OUT THERE ON
WOODS IN ORDINANCES WE'VE DONE
A GREAT JOB OF PULLING PEOPLE
TO CLEAR THEIR ERROR. OF
NATURAL VEGETATION TO PROVIDE-
BUFFER FOR THE FIRES AND TO
HAVE A PLAN TO LEAVE WITH DONE
GREAT. AND THEN WE'VE ALLOWED
THEM TO PLANT STICKS OF
DYNAMITE. IN THEIR PLANNERS
SURROUNDING THE HOUSES AND WHEN
YOU SEE THE ORNAMENTAL
VEGETATION GO UP. IT'S AMAZING
ALL THIS GOOD STUFF IN PLACE
AND THE ORNAMENT OF IT
VEGETATION. CAN TAKE OUT A
HOUSE BECAUSE IT IGNITES MORE
READILY THAN EVEN THE NATURAL
VEGETATION SO SOME THOUGHTS
ABOUT THAT I THINK ARE
IMPORTANT. THE OTHER THING IS
ON ORDERING- THAT THIS ORDERING
SYSTEM BACK AT THE STATION FAR
WE HAVE COOPERATING AGENCIES
AND YOU'VE HEARD A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOW WE NEED TO COOPERATE
LOCALLY AND WE DO THAT WE GET
ON THE PHONES WE SHARE
RESOURCES. BUT WHEN YOU HAVE
ONE AGE ZERO FIVE PARTS. AND
THAT FIRE IS BY IN DIRECT OF
OTHER A- WHETHER MINUTE. OR A
THE DIRECTION BUT AND STATE. OR
FOR AREA. WE HAVE A FIVE
COMMAND. AND IT'S FRUSTRATING
TO HAVE DECISIONS BE MADE
SOMETIMES WITHOUT THAT INPUT.
AND IN FACT WE THINK AT THE
STATION FIRE HAD WE BEEN ABLE
TO GET MORE STATE RESOURCES-
FROM US FOREST SERVICE IN
AIRCRAFT AND- THINK OF THE WORD
THAT YOU HEARD EARLIER TODAY.
WE WERE COMPETING FOR SIR THIS.
IS AMAZING THAT WE HAVE A
SYSTEM. THAT WE HAVE TO COMPETE
A COMPETITION. FOR RESOURCES
BETWEEN EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM.
THAT MEANS SOMEBODY'S GONNA WIN
AND SOMEBODY'S GOING TO LOSE
AND THE PEOPLE THAT LOSE ON THE
COMPETITION IF THEY'RE FACING
AN INCIDENT THAT HITS THE LIVES
AND PROPERTY ARE GOING TO BE
LOST. ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS I
WOULD LIKE TO TELL YOU IS THAT.
THE PRE POSITIONING MONEY. I'VE
BEEN A PRETTY TESTIFIED THAT TO
A GOD SEND OF A PLAN. WE ARE
STILL IN PRE RECESSION STAFFING
LEVELS.WE'VE CLIMBED OUT OF
THE RECESSION WE BUILT OUR
ECONOMIES BACK THE STATE IS
HEALTHIER WE NEED TO RE EXAMINE
RESOURCES. STAFF WHAT. AND THE
MONEY. IN THE POSITION MONEY. A
BACK TO PRE RECESSION LEVELS SO
THAT MUNICIPAL AGENCIES
CALIFORNIA THE FORRESTER. IN
FACT CAN PARTICIPATE ROBUSTLY
IN THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM WHEN
YOU HAVE SMALL MUNICIPAL
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE SENDING
THE RESOURCES OUT EVEN LARGE
AGENCIES WE CAN'T DO THAT IF WE
DON'T GET REIMBURSEMENT WE
CAN'T DO THAT IF WE DON'T KNOW
IT OTHER AGENCIES WILL BE ABLE
TO BACK FILL OUR- MYSTIC INS.
AND PROTECT THE IN AREAS. ON
THE SHOOTING MONEY WE LOOK AT
ALL THE WITH AND WE DO OUR BEST
TO PUT RESOURCES IN THE AREAS
WERE FIRE MIGHT STRIKE AND I
CAN TELL YOU WHEN IT DOES STRAP
WE HAVE AN IMMERSION OF
RESOURCES. THERE WERE ANY OTHER
FIRES THE TWO DAYS THAT NOBODY
WILL EVER HEAR ABOUT. IN
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN CONSUMED. THAT ALL OF THE
MEN AND WOMEN THAT WE REPRESENT
IN THIS ROOM INCLUDING MYSELF
ON THE LINES. THAT WE PUT THOSE
FIRES OUT VERY. QUICKLY BECAUSE
WE HAD THE RESOURCES WE HAD THE
AIRCRAFT WE HAVE THE
COOPERATING AGENCIES. SO WITH
THAT I YIELD THE REST OF MY
TIME IN FACT BOTH. THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE REPRESENTED. OF
THESE STRONGEST LEADERS FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY THAT I KNOW IN
THE ROOM. AND I CHALLENGE YOU
TO MAKE THE SYSTEM MORE ROBUST
AND BETTER AND SET IT TO PROVE
SESSION LEVELS TO TAKE CARE OF.
FIGHTERS THE YIELD. THEN BY
DOING THAT TAKING CARE OF VERY
THAT. I'LL SERVING OR JUST.
THANK YOU MUCH. THANK YOU
CAPTAIN. THE SUN S. IS NOT
HEARING SO MADAM CHAIR JACKSON
FOR THANK VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
ME HERE MY NAME IS TONY DOLLARS
AND THE FIRE CHIEF FOR THE CITY
SANTA ROSA I'M ALSO THE
OPERATIONAL OR NEAR FOR THE
COUNTY OF CINEMA. I'M THE
OPERATIONAL COORDINATOR
ESSENTIALLY HELPS MOVE MUTUAL
AID EQUIPMENT IN AND OUT OF THE
COUNTY WHEN IT'S REQUESTED I
DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE
INVITATION TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS THIS JOINT LEGISLATIVE
HEARING ON WILDFIRES HERE TWO
YEARS AGO IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. AND WE ALWAYS TALK
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AND BEYOND THIS REALLY IS BEEN
GOING ON FOR MUCH LONGER PERIOD
IN MY NECK OF THE WOODS SONOMA
COUNTY NAPA LAKE AREA ON THE
BALLOT FIRE STARTED IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE HAD THE-
RESUME FOR OURS. MANY THEY- AND
WE FORWARD TO SEVENTEEN AND WE
HAD THE TUBS FIRE. A REMINDER
THE TOUCH FIRESTAR IN COUNTY
TWELVE MILES AWAY FROM SANTA
ROSA WITHIN THREE HOURS IT WAS
IN SANTA ROSA. IN WITHIN SIX
MORE HOURS- THE FIRE PRETTY
MUCH STOPPED ALL FOR
PROGRESSION BUT IN THAT TIME
BURNED ABOUT FIFTY SIX HONOR
BUILDINGS. IT IS A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF FIRE THAT YOU HAVE TO
DEAL WITH- I WILL TELL YOU AT-
AT BY TWELVE THIRTY AT NIGHT WE
HAD SEVENTY EIGHT STRIKE TEAMS
REQUESTED. FORTY WERE FOR THE
INCIDENT WHICH WAS THE TUBS
FIRE WHICH STARTED IN NAPA. AND
ADD THE REMAINDER- WAS ORDERED
THROUGH CINEMA COUNTY. THE
MAJORITY OF THOSE RESOURCES
SHOWED UP AFTER SIX O'CLOCK IN
THE MORNING WHEN MOST OF THE
DAMAGE WAS DONE. AND THAT'S
REALLY WHAT WE'RE HERE TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT WE NEED IS WE HAVE
THE BEST MUTUAL AID SYSTEM IN
THE COUNTRY. WE REALLY DO. BUT
IT'S GOOD FOR TWELVE TO THIRTY
SIX HOURS OUT ON THOSE NO
NOTICE EVENTS THAT THAT WOULD
LOOK AT TODAY. AND A LOT OF
THESE FIRES THAT ARE START
LEAST IN MY NECK OF THE WOODS
ARE STARTING AT NINE OR TEN
O'CLOCK AT NIGHT WHEN. PEOPLE
ARE STE. MOST FIRST TIME. FOR
FIRE AND IN THE IN THE NEXT
EXAMPLE TALK TALK ABOUT A
MINUTE THE KINCAID WE'RE THE
MIDDLE OF A P. S. P. S.
MULTIPLE PSP **** WHICH MET.
MARCEL SERVICE WAS THAT ON
PEOPLE DIDN'T HAVE POWER IT WAS
HARD TO GET COMMUNICATIONS OUT.
WE WERE. SPACE THAN FIVE
GOVERNOR SPACE IN WERE YEARS
AGO. AT THE FIRES THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING A BURNING HOTTER
FASTER THEY'RE NOT LAYING DOWN
AT NIGHT THEY'RE BURNING- JUST
AS GOOD AT NIGHT AS THEY ARE-
IN IN THE DAYLIGHT- JUST LAST
OUT OF MY HOUSE. IT WAS A
BEAUTIFUL ORANGE MOON COMING UP
THE WIND WAS BLOWING OUT MY
BACK IT WAS WARM AND I'M LOOK
AND IT'S FAIR. TENTH RIGHT.
THANK GET A SMALL NUMBER IT
MADE ME STEP IN THINK WHAT THE
CLOCK AND I MISS THIS DOES FEEL
RIGHT. FOR FEBRUARY SO IT
DIFFERENT THERE AND WE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT. AND THE MUTUAL
AID SO. IS SUCH THAT IT'S JUST
A LITTLE TO CUMBERSOME TO GET
EQUIPMENT WHERE WE NEED IT. ON
THOSE NO NOTICE EVENTS THE TUBS
FIRE THE VALLEY FIRE THE
JERUSALEM THE ROCKY ALL THOSE
WE LOST MANY HOMES. AND ASK IN
MY NECK OF THE WOODS. AT THE
KING FIRE FAST FOR THE KINCAID
FIRE. AND THE ONLY FIRE THAT
BURNING. AT THE TIME AND START
AROUND NINE FOUR AT NIGHT. WE
HAD TH LOCAL. PREPAID RESOURCES
WE WHAT HAD ONE OH YES RIGHT
TEAM FROM THE REST PRE POSITION
THEY ALL WENT TO THE FIRE. DID
SOME GREAT WORK- WILL CAL FIRE
WAS IN CHARGE OF THE INCIDENT
AND THEY THEY ORDERED A QUICK
MEANT TO DEAL WITH WHAT THEY
HAD- AND IT WILL THE ONLY FIRE
IN TOWN RIGHT. THAT ALLOWED IT
TO BUILD IT AND THE TEAM BILLS
FROM RESOURCES IN- AND- PLAN
WHICH WE DIDN'T HAVE FOR THE
TUBS FIRE WILL SOME OF THESE
EXAMPLE OTHERS EXAMPLES. WAS
JUST NO TOP. WE THIS TIME. AND
NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE WE HAD A.
IN A SMALLER AIRCRAFT BUT IN
THIS. WE ALL EVACUATED TO SEE
PILLS BURGER TOWN A WIN. THE
GREATER MONEY SNOW MACAU I
THINK OF UPWARDS OF A HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT
WERE BACK WAITED WE HAD ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT WE EVENT WHAT
TWENTIETH. EIGHT ON FOR. RIGHT
SO WE HAD AN THIS AND PROBABLY
FOR THOUSAND. PEOPLE FAIR CAMP
OR ELITE ASSIGNED TO THE CAN'T.
WHEN YOU GOT A SPLIT UP THEY
CAN BE OUT ON FIERY SHIP WORK
RIGHT YOU NEED SO FOR THE DAY.
BUT WHEN THEY WERE BURNING OF
THE COMMUNITIES. WERE AND I WAS
PARTY UNIFIED COMMAND WITH TEAM
SIX. THERE WAS A POINT WHERE
LIKE IT WE EITHER GET THOSE
PEOPLE THAT ARE SLEEPING IN
CAMP UP AND WE GET A MEMBER OF
THE NEIGHBORHOODS BECAUSE WE
GOT FIRESTARTER BURN AND HILLS
BERGEN IN WINDSOR. OR I GOT A
REACH OUT AROUND- YES AND GO TO
MY REGION AND COUNTIES AROUND
ME TO GET RESOURCES IN HERE
BECAUSE IT'S STARTING THE
IMPACT THE TOWN F WINDSOR. AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE DID I
HAD- CHIEF ROACH ON THE LINE
AND SAID CAN YOU CAN YOU SPARE
ANY EQUIPMENT AND GOES LET ME
GET BACK WE WERE START HAVE POP
UP ON OUR BECAUSE THE WILL OF
IT WAS. A ONE. OUR MARIN COUNTY.
SENATE A STRIKE TEAM PLOY ARE
WE OR ANOTHER STRETCHING FOR
LOCAL CAN LOCAL UNITS WITH
INSTANT COUNTY AND WE PUSH THEM
ALL INTO WINDSOR WITH THE OTHER
EQUIPMENT THAT IS A SIGN AND
THEY DID GREAT GREAT WORK AND
I'LL TELL YOU THAT'S WHAT ONE
TALKING ABOUT THIS I THOUGHT IT
WAS VERY VERY SUCCESSFUL IT. IT
WAS AN AGO ATION BETWEEN THE
UNIFIED COMMANDERS MYSELF PART
OF IT IS A THESE RESOURCES COME
AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ASSIGNED TO THE TO THE ANSWER
THEY BECOME OURS SEC NO WE
CAN'T DO THAT THESE ARE SURGE
UNITS TO HELP WITH THE FIRE
WHEN A TRUCK STOP THIS FIRE SO
DOESN'T BURN ANOTHER COMMUNITY
AND ONE AT THREE DOT GO BACK IN
BECAUSE WE STILL HAVE
COMMUNITIES WE NEED TECH WE
HAVE A LOT OF ME. CAN'T YOU CAN.
EVERYTHING BECAUSE OF THE WIND
CHANGES WE HAVE A PRETTY IDEA
OF WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN BUT YOU
NEVER KNOW TELL IT'S GOING TO
HAVE. AND WE YOU THE SURGE
PLANS THE CAN CADE PROBABLY
THREE DIFFERENT TIMES- VERY
SUCCESSFULLY. AND THE REASON I
BRING IT UP IT'S A LOT LIKE
WHAT CHIEF LEARNS AND SAID IT'S
THIS THIS. FORMULA FOR GETTING
RESOURCES AND EVEN THOUGH YOU
HAVE AS- A QUICK MINUTE SONG
AND- YOU'LL NEVER HAVE ENOUGH
TO DEAL WITH ALL THE ENTITIES
THAT YOU NEED ALL THE- IS THAT
YOU NEED. SO USE THESE FORCE TO
SURGERY. DEAL THE THREAT. AND
TWELVE HOURS WE CENTER HOME.
NOW I UNDERSTAND BECOMES A
LITTLE BIT OF AN ACCOUNT NIGHT
FOR YES CAL LOOK GOVERNMENT I
WE HAD A WORKS ALL OF THAT BUT
WE USED THE MAJORITY OF IT IS
MASTER MUTUAL AID WHICH MEANS
THIS MUTUAL AID. THEY COME THEY
DO THEY WORK TO GO HOME AND AS
PART OF THE AS BEING
OPERATIONAL COORDINATOR I'D
HELD A CONFERENCE CALL. FOR
WITH ALL THE FIRST PERSON THEY
SAID HEY WE THIS WE HAVE THAT
MY HISTORIC ONE EVENT. TWENTY
ACRES ON FIRE I NEED IT UP UP
AS MUCH. IT MAY COME. OR IT MAY
COME LATER TO. WE WON'T KNOW
BUT WE NEED EVERYONE READY. AND
I WILL TELL YOU CINEMA COUNTY
SET UP IN A THEY- THEY- WHEN WE
MADE THE ALL CALL THEY HAD
FIFTY ENGINE CERTAIN- REAL
CLOSE TO WHERE THEY CONCERT.
RIGHT SO. IT DOES WORK- BUT
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR. ALL OF US
IN THE PROFESSION- YES CAL FIRE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. TO KINDA
RANGEL THAT RIGHT BECAUSE- WE
TALK ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY WE
TALK ABOUT SAFETY WHAT DOES IT
MEAN WE GAVE EVERYONE A TALE
MORE BRIEFING. WE MADE SURE
EVERYONE HADTHE COMMON. FEEL
COMMUNICATIONS WE TIED IN WITH
THE DIVISIONS OR WHOEVER THEY
NEEDED TO ON HIGHER. THAN THEIR
WORK. AND THEY WERE RELEASED IN
ONE HOME. THAT IT WORKED THIS
TIME AND I THOUGHT IT WORKED
REALLY WELL I THINK SOUTHERN.
DOESN'T SEEM TO A CERTAIN
EXTENT BUT THAT'S WHERE WE HAVE
TO GO BECAUSE WE CANNOT GET THE
RESOURCES FAST ENOUGH- AS FAR
AS THE SITUATIONAL AWARENESS IF
WE JUST WE DON'T KNOW HOW. BIG
HOW FAST IT'S MOVING MOST OF
THE TIME AT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LEVEL RIGHT WE HAVE
SATELLITES WE HAVE DRONES AS
DRONES WE HAD IT ON THE CAN CAN
I THINK IT HAPPENED ON THE
SECOND THURSDAY. WE NEED IT OUR
FIRST DAY RIGHT SO WE CAN
MONITOR. IF YES IS LOOKING AT
THAT INFORMATION NOW WE GOT
SIGNIFICAN FAR WE NEED TO START
PUSHING RESOURCES AND NOW.
INSTEAD OF WAITING FOR TED TO
WORK THROUGH THE PROCESS. THE
TUBS FIRE INDICATE FIRE WERE
CAL FIRE INCIDENTS. SO YOU TALK
ABOUT UNIFIED OR REPORTS YOU
PUT IN ORDER FOR FORTY UNITS A
GOES TO CAL FIRE. CAL FIRE IS
GETTING INUNDATED WITH PHONE
CALLS THEY HAVE TO PROCESS. THE
STRIKE TEAMS. GOES THE MORE
POPULAR DAHLE FOBS. RIGHT BUT
BEFORE EVEN GOES THE YES SO CAL
FIRE NO YES WELL THEIR
PARTNERS. THEIR SEPARATE CAL
FIRE HAS ITS MISSION- YES HAS
THEIR MISSION. SO WHAT ARE
THOSE TWO YEARS AGO. HE HAS
LIKE LOOK AT THEIR AN ORDER
FORTY STRIKING HAVE GO CAL FIRE
WEATHER CAL FIRES IN OR NOT AND
THE OTHER GOOD YEAH. TO GET THE
IN THE- THERE AS QUICK AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE WILL BURN IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD. IF IT'S IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE FOREST WE
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY QUITE. AS
MUCH. AS RIGHT BUT- FOR THE ONE
IS BURNING IN THE COMMUNITIES
SEC WE HAVE TO BE. DIFFERENT IN
TERMS OF HOW WE APPROACH THIS
IS HOW WE GET RESOURCES IN. IT
TAKES TIME. I TOTALLY GET THAT
EVERY UNDER. THAT WE JUST WANT
TO. IT IS. AS GOOD AS WE CAN
FOR THE CITIZENS. OF
CALIFORNIA. I DON'T LIVE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ON THE COAST. WE ARE
ALL IMPACTED WITH TODAY'S
WEATHER WERE ALL IMPACTED WITH
THE FIRES THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING. IN WE HAVE THE
POWER TO MAKE IT DIFFERENT. WE
BUT WE NEED HELP DOING THAT.
AND I THINK EVERYONE SEES THE
VALUE THAT IS JUST HOW DO WE
BREAK DOWN AND MAKE IT WORK THE
MOST EFFICIENT AND SAFE.
EVERYONE IN WHAT BUT ALL ALL
STOP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF.
THANK YOU TO. THE CHIEF RENDON
WHO'S GONNA BE MAY PRE PREPARE
REMARKS OF A SHE FOR A. I WOULD
LIKE TO READ THE RUMOR OF JAY
ROACH IN THE REC GOOD AFTER. I
AM DAVID ROACH I AM THE FIRE
CHIEF OF THE TO FIRE TO. I ALSO
SERVE AS CHAIR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA METROPOLITAN FIRE
CHIEFS WHICH IS MADE UP OF THE
SIXTEEN LARGEST IN THE
MUNICIPAL FIRE DEPARTMENTS IN
THE STATE. MY REMARKS TODAY
SELECT AN ADDITIONAL ROLE I
PLAY AS A CAL- YES REGION TO
FIRE AND RESCUE COORDINATOR.
THE POSITION I AM ELECTED TO
BUY FIRE CHIEFS FROM SIXTEEN
COASTAL COUNTIES FROM MONTEREY
COUNTY TO THE OREGON BORDER.
REGION TWO IS ONE OF SIX MUTUAL
AID REGIONS THAT FUNCTIONALLY
CONNECT CAL- YES TO OPERATIONAL
AREAS. YOU CAN THINK OF
OPERATIONAL AREAS AS COUNTIES
BECAUSE THAT IS HOW THEY'RE
STRUCTURED. WITH THE EXCEPTIONS
OF THE TAHOE BASIN IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. THE SIX REGION
COORDINATORS ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR MAINTAINING REGIONAL FIRE
AND RESCUE RESOURCE
AVAILABILITY AND THE
COORDINATION OF MUTUAL AID
WITHIN THE REGION AS WELL AS
FILLING ORDERS TO OTHER REGIONS.
COORDINATORS ALSO ORGANIZE
STAFF AND EQUIP THE REGION
COORDINATION DISPATCH CENTER.
THIS IS USUALLY DONE AT THE
HOST AGENCIE COST. IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY WE ARE FORTUNATE TO HAVE
A BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THAT
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF
MUTUAL AID. WE PROVIDE THE
STATE WITH NOT ONLY A FIRE AND
RESCUE REGION COORDINATOR. BUT
ALSO REGION COORDINATORS FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND HEALTH CARE
ACTIVITIES. THIS ADDITIONAL BUT
NECESSARY DUTY PLACES AND
UNFUNDED BURDEN ON THE HOST
FIRE DEPARTMENT LIKE ALAMEDA
COUNTY FIRE. WE MUST STAFF FOR
POTENTIAL ADVANCE AND TRAIN ON
SYSTEMS PROVIDED BY THE STATE
SO WE ARE ALWAYS READY. FOR
THESE REASONS IS SOMETIMES
DIFFICULT TO FIND AGENCIES WHO
HAVE THE CAPABILITY OR
OTHERWISE WILLING TO BE A
REGION COORDINATOR OR AN
OPERATIONAL AREA COORDINATOR.
IN REGION TWO FOR EXAMPLE WE
HAVE STRUGGLED TO FIND AN
AGENCY THEY CAN COMMIT TO
FUNCTIONING AS OUR OWN BACK UP.
BE THAT AS IT CAL FIRE LIKE
NAPA UNIT IS THE DESIGNATED
BACK UP WHICH BRINGS ITS OWN
SET OF CHALLENGES. NEEDLESS TO
SAY THEY HAVE BEEN A VERY BUSY
UNIT IN THE LAST FEW YEARS AND
THE DOOR CALLOW YES CAL FIRE
ROLE LEADS TO EXCEPTIONAL
WORKLOADS FOR ALREADY
UNDERSTAFFED DISPATCH CENTERS.
DURING INCIDENTS A REGION
COORDINATION DISPATCH CENTER IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR DISPATCHING ALL
CAL- YES AND LOCAL FIRE AND
RESCUE RESOURCES. WITHIN THE
REGION TO MAJOR MUTUAL AID
OPERATIONS OR FIRES SUCH AS
THOSE DISCUSSED EARLIER.
DISPATCH CENTERS IN THE
INCIDENT ARE OFTEN OVERWHELMED
WITH THE INCOMING CALLS IN
DISPATCH DUTIES WHICH MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO REACH OUT
TO THE REGION COORDINATOR FOR
HELP. DURING THE OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES MY
DISPATCHERS COULD NOT EVEN
REACH THE LOCAL OPERATIONAL
AREA COORDINATION CENTERS IN
NAPA AND SONOMA TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES. FROM THE BAY AREA.
CALIFORNIA LAKE NAPA UNIT WAS
OVERWHELMED WITH CALLS FROM THE
PUBLIC AND RESOURCE ORDERS THE
FIRST OFFICIAL ORDER FILLED BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAME SEVERAL
HOURS AFTER THE FIRST REQUEST
FROM A FIELD INCIDENT COMMANDER
TO THEIR LOCAL DISPATCH CENTER.
STILL NOT ENOUGH IN HINDSIGHT
OPERATIONAL AREAS LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO CONTRA COSTA AND
ALAMEDA SEND STRIKE TEAMS FIVE
ENGINES AND CHIEF OFFICER
BEFORE THOSE ORDERS WERE EVEN
RECEIVED. EVENTUALLY THOSE
ORDERS CAME THROUGH THE SYSTEM
BUT WE SIMPLY COULDN'T AFFORD
TO WAIT INTO THE OFFICIAL
ORDERS CAME AND- UNFORTUNATELY.
THE CURRENT RESOURCE ORDERING
AND STATUS SYSTEM OR ROSS AS IT
IS CALLED IS CUMBERSOME AND TOO
SLOW TO ADDRESS THE RESOURCES
BEING ORDERED AT THE ONSET OF
THESE FAST GROWING FIRES. IT'S
A THIRTY YEAR OLD FEDERAL
SYSTEM DESIGNED MORE FOR
ACCOUNTING PURPOSES IN NEEDS TO
BE UPDATED AS YOU'VE HEARD THE
SLOW ROSS ENVIRONMENT HAS LED
SOME LOCAL AGENCIES BIG AND
SMALL TO BYPASS THE SYSTEM. IN
FAVOR OF DIRECTLY CALLING
THEIR- NEIGHBORS FOR ASSISTANCE.
BECAUSE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS PROVIDED ROSS ESSENTIALLY
FOR FREE IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
FINANCIAL COMMENDED COMMITMENT
TO BRING ABOUT CHANGE. WE NEED
TO INVEST IN TECHNOLOGY THAT
ALLOWS US TO EFFICIENTLY
EFFECTIVELY AND SAFELY DEPLOY
OUR FIREFIGHTERS. THE GOOD NEWS
IS THAT CAL O. S. PRE
pEXPANDED TO INCLUDE DISPATCHERS
AS WELL AS COMMAND AND CONTROL
OVERHEAD STAFF. LAST YEAR PRE
POSITIONING FUNDING WAS
APPROVED TO STAFF EXTRA
DISPATCHERS IN HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY CONDITIONS AT BOTH THE
REGION AND OPERATIONAL DISPATCH
CENTERS. THE IMPACT OF THE PRE
POSITIONING OF RESOURCES ON
OCTOBER TWENTY SEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN HAD A
SIGNIFICANT POSITIVE PACKED IN
CONTROLLING MULTIPLE FIRE IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. RESOURCE
WERE DRAWN DOWN DUE TO THE
KINCAID FIRE AND MUCH OF THE
STATE WAS IMPACTED BY THE PGA
ANY. PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
OFF. MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES WERE ALREADY SORT
ENGINES AND FIREFIGHTERS THE
FUNDING FOR PRE POSITIONING
BROUGHT RESOURCES INTO THE EAST
BAY WHICH ALLOWED ME TO PROVIDE
CONTRA COSTA. WITH THE HAMMER
THEY NEEDED TO CONTROL TEN
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT FIRES
WHILE MY AGENCY MAINTAINED ITS
ABILITY TO RESPOND TO OVER. TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY INCIDENTS IN OUR
OWN AREA OVER THE SAME EIGHTEEN
HOUR PERIOD. IN CLOSING. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES THROUGH
CALIFORNIA PLAY SIGNIFICANT
ROLES AS OPERATIONAL AREA
COORDINATOR AND REGION
COORDINATORS WHICH ALL ALLOW US
TO WORK TOGETHER AS A UNIFIED
FORCE DURING LARGE SCALE EVENTS
BUT WE NEED TO MAKE MORE
INVESTMENTS IN THE SYSTEMS AND
TECHNOLOGY WE USED TO ENSURE
THE INTEGRATED SYSTEM IS
FUNCTIONING QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY SO WE ARE IN THE
BEST POSITION TO SAVE LIVES AND
PROPERTY. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRS. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY SPEAK IN FRONT
OF YOU TODAY- MY NAME'S STEVE
KOVACS ON THE FIRE CHIEF OF THE
SCOTTS VALLEY FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
AND ON THE CURRENT PRESIDENT OF
THE FIRE DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
AND- BOX. THREE HUNDRED. SIX
SIX OF THIS. I'M ALSO CURRENTLY
ONE OF THE OPERATIONAL RECORDED
OR OF ACCOUNT IMPROVE SERVED
THAT SAME AND CALIBERS FOR THE
SEVEN YEAR PRIOR ALSO HAVING
SERVED ON THE FIRST BORDER
DIRECTORS. TWENTY FIRE SYSTEMS
AGREEMENT GOSHEN COMMITTEE AND
AS OF ALL REP. AND ON THE STATE
BOARD OF FIRE SERVICES- I'LL BE
SHARING WITH YOU A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE TODAY-
MOSTLY FROM THE SMALL AGENCY.
SIDE OF THINGS AND THE IMPACTS
OF MUTUAL AID SYSTEM HAS ON
THOSE. LOOK GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
SAT THROUGH MUTUAL AID SYSTEM-
CREATE A LINE SURE RESOURCES.
ON ANY MAJOR WHILE AND FIRE
WITHIN THE STATE- WE MAKE UP
THE LARGEST DEPTH OF AVAILABLE
ASSETS- FOR THESE INCIDENTS.
SMALLER AGENCIES CONTRIBUTE
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FIVE TO
FORTY PERCENT. OF RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO THE SYSTEM. ALL
THERE ARE INHERENT CHAO. THAT
COME DO THAT LACK ASIDE. YOU
DON'T HAVE THE DEPTH OF APPLE
AND PER TO GIVE TO THE SO.
PHONE AGENCIES OFTEN HAVE A
LACK OF STAFFING TO COVER THEIR
OWN JURISDICTIONS ADEQUATELY
AND ARE. RELUCTANT TO GIVE UP
RESOURCES FOR FEAR THE
RAMIFICATIONS ON THE HOME FRONT
IF AN AGENCY ONLY STAFF TO FIRE
ENGINES ON A DAILY BASIS AND
THEY GIVE UP ONE OF THOSE THAT
REDUCES THEIR RESOURCES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE BY 50% GOVERNING
BODIES ARE ALWAYS COMFORTABLE
FACED WITH THESE- PARTICULAR
SITUATIONS SO. MAJOR FIRES
FIRES AS YOU'VE HEARD ALREADY-
SELDOM HAPPEN AT ONE TIME. AND
WE NEED ALL THE AGENCIES IN THE
FIGHT SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
AVAILABLE RESOURCES TO MUTUAL
AID SYSTEM HAS BEEN REDUCED BY
APPROXIMATELY 30% MANY OF THAT
NUMBER. ARE FROM SMALLER
AGENCIES THAT HAVE A HAVE A
HARDER TIME RECOVERING FROM THE
RECESSION. SMALL AGENCIES HAVE
ALSO BEEN HIT THE ARDEST BY
NUMEROUS FUNDING ISSUES
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS- STARTING
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WITH
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN ALTHOUGH
THIS WAS VERY GOOD FOR THE TAX
PAYER I IT WAS DEVASTATING FOR
FIRED. THAT RELY UPON THIS IS
THE MADE SOURCE OF REVENUE.
NINETY TWO NOW THE PERMANENT
10% LOSS PROPERTY TO. YEAR
AFTER YEAR SHIFTED SCHOOLS.
THIS IS CALLED ERA SB TWO FIVE
FIVE SEVEN FEES AND NOT GETTING
A FAIR SHARE OF PROP ONE
SEVENTY TWO FUNDING IN MANY
COUNTIES. IN ADDITION THERE ARESOME AGENCIES ARE REFUSED TO
CONTRIBUTE MUTUAL AID RESOURCES
DUE TO THE CHALLENGER
REIMBURSEMENT. AND RECOVERING
THE TOTAL COST OF THE RESPONSE.
MOSTLY IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA BEACH LATE SYSTEM IS
EXECUTED BY PERSONNEL EXPECTED
TO PERFORM THIS WORK ON AS A
COLLATERAL DUTY. IN ABSORB THE
SURGE CAPACITY WHICH MAY HAVE
BEEN FINE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
BUT IS NOT IN OUR CURRENT ERA.
THE CURRENT SYSTEM DOES NOT
HAVE THE PROPER STAFFING
UTILIZES FULL CAPABILITY AND A
CITY DURING THOSE TIMES OF
SEARCH THE RESPONSIBILITIES ARE
PUSHED TO THE REGION
COORDINATORS DOWN OF THE
OPERATIONAL AREA COORDINATORS
BUT DO NOT PROVIDE PROPEL. THE
PORT THE EXTRA WORK. RIGHT FOR
ON STRATEGY TO SECURELY TERM
FINANCE FIND SUPPORT FIRST
UNDER FUNDED FOR AGE. ENSURE
FUNDING FOR STAFFING IS
AVAILABLE TO FULL UNIFIED
UTILIZE THE CAPACITY OF THE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM. THEN ACT
LEGISLATION TO FIX THE ISSUES
FACED WITH BY AGENCIES THAT
MUST TAKE FIREFIGHTERS IN AN
OUT OF VOLUNTEER STATUS WITHOUT
PENALTIES OF LABOR LAW
VIOLATIONS. OUR PRECIPITATION
THIS YEAR HAS BEEN. BELOW
NORMAL IN MOST PARTS OF THE
STATE IN THE NEXT FIRE SEASON
WILL BE SOON UPON. URBAN ISSUES
MUST BE ADDRESSED AND CANNOT
WAIT FOR LONG TERM SOLUTIONS-
CALIFORNIAN JOYS THE MOST
ROBUST MUTUAL AID SYSTEM IN THE
WORLD ARE FIRE ENVIRONMENT HAS
CHANGED. MY MUTILATE SYSTEM WAS
ALSO CHANGE WITH. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO ADDRESS TO THE-
AND ALL TO. THANK YOU CHIEF EN
HAVE ALL SHE ADDRESS. THANK YOU
SHARES IN MEMBERS OF THE JOINT
LIST WE CAN ON EMERGING
MANAGEMENT IT'S OBVIOUSLY HONOR
TO BE HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY. HI
MY NAME'S EVAN LOW. THE FIRE
CHIEF FOR THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
FIRE DEPARTMENT IT ALSO SERVES
THE PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
FAR TOO SO. HAVE YOU HEARD FROM
COLLEAGUES TODAY WE HAVE A VERY
IMAGE TO. BUT ONE THE NEEDS TO
BE MARK. TO ME TODAY DEEDS AND
STATE DEMAND. GIVEN THE HERB
INTERFACE HOUSING IN. GROWTH
AND CAL. AS WELL EFFECTS OF
CHANGE OUR STATE. WE SIMPLY
CANNOT CONTINUE TO DO WHAT
WE'VE ALWAYS DONE. AND EXPECTS
SUCCESSFUL RESULTS. TWO YEARS
AGO. AT THIS COMMITTEE HERE ALL
THE STATE'S FIRE SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING CAL
SHE'S FAR DISTRICTS. LEGAL
CALIFORNIA PART SECTION.
CALIFORNIA METRO CHIEFS
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE FOR PRESENTATIONS WE
FORMED A COALITION CALLED THE
RISK. WHICH IS THE PASTOR
READINESS FOR COMMUNITY. T.
ADVOCATE FOR TESTING. OF PLANT
MODERN. OUR MUTUALLY COME. WE
SAW NAY A MARTYR THE TECH.
THAT'S A TO STAY MUTUAL ESTA.
TO PROCESS REQUEST. RESOURCES
EFFECTIVELY AND MORE
EFFICIENTLY. MARK DOLLARS BE
PROPER TAPPING AND ARE WE DON'T.
EMERGING BAD CENTER. WHICH WE
TALKED. WE SHOULD BE RALPH
BELLAMY. IS LOCATED SENATE
APPROPRIATE UNITS IN THIS. AND
DO IT. AS YOU HEARD IT TAKES
OUR AND SOMETIMES DAYS. TO
PROCESS WE AND WE- THIS IS
SIMPLY NOT ACCEPTABLE. IN THE
PAST TWO FISCAL YEARS. WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO SEE AN THAT AGAIN
FOR YOUR GREAT SUPPORT OVER
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
YOU. STATE TO HELP BUT FAR AS
AN EQUIPMENT IN PLACE A BAD. WE
CALL POSITIONING. WE DON'T KNOW
IT IS ASKING US. YOU KNOW IF WE
HAVE THE WEATHER CONDITION. THE
TOPOGRAPHY. AND WE CAN IT'S A
HARD AND FAST. WE CAN MAKE A
GREAT DIFFERENCE SO FOR THIS
FISCAL YEAR ALONE WE SPENT
CLOSE TO EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
OF THOSE FUNDS WE STILL HAVE
ALMOST THE- WE- WINNER THROUGH.
GIVE ME THE FOR MANY MONTHS THE
SUN WHICH CA BE. ON LEE WE'VE
NOT MADE A WHOLE OF PROPER IN
THE AREA OF TECHNO. HOW FAR HAS
MOVED FORWARD ON THE- VIEW
LOCATOR OR AB ELSE'S. AND MERGE
UNITS. THE STATE OKAY. HAS ALEC
FONG. TO PLACES. IN BOTH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT RESOURCE. IN OUR
STATE ALL MORE SERVICES A QUICK.
THAT WE HAVE ACROSS THE STATE.
CAN FOR A MOMENT AND THIS IS
BUT IT'S TRUE THAT CAN USE
TECHNOLOGY EVERYDAY TO TRACKER
LEFT. YOU CAN WATCH THEM GO
DOWN THE STREET YOU CAN CALL
DOMINO'S AND TRACK YOUR PIZZA
HATE AND DELIVERED TO YOUR HOME.
THAT TECHNOLOGY EXISTS BUT WE
CAN'T POINT TODAY WERE LOCAL
GROUP GOVERNMENT RESOURCES ARE
AT ANY GIVEN TIME. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT EMERGENCY UNITS AND
STAFFING MAKE UP APPROX ME
7280% OF THE RESOURCES ON THESE
LARGE FIRES. YOU CAN CALL THE
TOP IN CALLED THE WALLS THE
FIRE BUT IS LOCAL GOVERNMENT
RESOURCES THAT'S OUR CHOI
BACKBONE THAT'S THE BACKBONE OF
OUR SYSTEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE FULLY IMPLEMENT OUR FIFTY
BROAD NEVER CALL FIRST AT TWO
WHICH FIRST RESPONDERS HAVE
ACCESS TO COMMUNICATE WITH EACH
OTHER WITHOUT COMPETING WITH
THE GENERAL PUBLIC ON CHURCH
SYSTEMS DURING HIS PASTOR. IN
SUMMARY WHAT SNARLING. TO SAY
THAT WE DO HAVE THE BEST MUTUAL
AID SYSTEM IN THE WORLD WE DO.
ARE THE ENVY OF THE WORLD
THERE'S NO STATE CAN POP
RESOURCES ALL THE CALIFORNIA.
WE JUST NEED TO IMPROVE IT. IN
A WORLD OF LIKE CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE A DISASTER PRONE STATE. WE
NEED TO GET THE RIGHT PUBLIC
SAFETY PROFESSIONALS TO THE
INCIDENT. AS EXPEDITIOUSLY AN
OFFICIAL POSSIBLE. WHAT CAN'T
CONTROL IS TO RESPONSE AND HOW
QUICKLY WE GET THEM THERE TO
CONTAIN WILDFIRES TO SAVE LIVES
PROPERTY OR VARMINT. WE LIKE TO
LEAVE YOU WITH FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS WE COULD TELL
COOPER SISKEL FIRST WE NEED TO
CONTINUE OUR PRE POSITIONING
FUND. OF RESOURCES ANNUALLY
SOMETIMES AMAME MANY MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR. THAT FUNDING I THINK
YOU'VE HAD SOME SUCCESS STORIES
TODAY OF SO LAW. PROPERTY IN
OUR ENVIRONMENT IN CALIFORNIA
SECOND THE EEVEE LZ AUTOMATIC
VEHICLE LOCATORS HAVE TO BE A
PRIORITY AT THE STATE TO GET
THAT IN THERE WE HAVE I HAVE
THAT MOMENT- THAT'LL- THE WERE
TO GO SO WE KNOW HOW DOES TO
DISPATCH RESOURCES. AND WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE. THIRD OUR
REGIONAL COMMUNICATIONS
CENTERS. IN THESE TIMES HAVE TO
BE UP STEP. THERE THE ONES
PRICE IN YOUR FIRST CALL IT.
THE TERMS OF THE AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE STATE. AND EIGHTEEN
T. ON FIRST NAY KNOWN TO FIRST
RESPONDERS NO ONE KNOWS WHAT'S
IN THE AGREEMENT. AND WE NEED
TO KNOW HOW TO MODIFY OUR
SYSTEMS WORK AT THAT SYSTEM. WE
NEED TO AGREEMENT TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT COMMUNICATE EFFECTIVELY.
THAT CONCLUDES ACOSTA MONEY OUR
TEAM STANDS READY THE QUESTIONS
FOR YOU HAVE OF US AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT.
AND WE STAND READY TO CONTINUE
TO PROTECT THE RESEARCH
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CHIEF SENATOR YEAH COULD I HAVE
YOUR THAT FOURTH ITEM WE- I'M
NOT SURE I GOT A COMPLETELY WE
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE EIGHT
IN T. CORRECT AN- TO A VICE
CHAIR OF WE DON'T HAVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAS NOT SEEN THE
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND EIGHTEEN T. ON
THE PROGRAM WE DON'T KNOW HOW
IT'S GOING AMENDED WE DON'T
KNOW THE BROWN CASE OF IT. THE
OTHER GOVERNMENT SO IF WE'RE
GONNA BE PART OF A SISTER WHICH
WE WILL BE TO FIRST WE NEED TO
BE AT THE TABLE AT THAT THAT
INFORMATION TO SEE WHAT THAT IS
AND THAT'S WHEN TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. HAS BEEN REQUESTED.
YEAH THANK YOU THANK YOU. I'D
LIKE TO EACH OF YOU FOR YOUR
IMPORTANT AND I HAVE A
QUESTIONS BUT I DO WANT TO OPEN
WITH SOME OBSERVATIONS AND
STARTING WITH- A LARGE AMOUNT
OF GRATITUDE BECAUSE TO CHIEF
LORENZEN'S POINT ABOUT
RESHAPING PUBLIC EXPECTATIONS
ONE OF THE FOR AS I DID ON AT
THE START OF LAST FIRE SEASON
WAS ACTUALLY HAVE PUBLIC SAFETY
WORKSHOPS. IN PREPARE FOR
HIGHER ANY TO THE AGENCY I READ
RIGHT HERE AT THE TABLE TODAY
GLADLY STEPPED UP AND WE FILLED
MULTIPURPOSE ROOMS IN EACH OF
THE THREE VALLEY'S IRAQ AND A
GROUP SAN FERNANDO. LISTEN
ALLEY. AND FOLK WHO'VE BEEN
THROUGH THAT WHILE SEASONS
MULTIPLE TIMES WE STILL
ASTONISHED AT THE LEVEL TWO
WHICH THEY KNEW TO ENGAGE AS
RESIDENTS AND HOMEOWNERS IN
THIS PROCESS AND THERE WAS
NOTHING MORE CLEAR THAN THEN
THE EXPERIENCE WITH THE WALLS
FIRE WE KNEW THAT IT WAS REAL.
FUNDAMENTALLY A BEING LIFE AT
THE POINT WHEN WE COULD ON HOW
THAT FIRE WAS MOVING WE SAW IT
AGAIN. IN NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR
WE HAD THE TECH FIRE WE HAVE
THE SADDLE RIDGE FIRE WE THE
EASY FIRE. WANTED PEOPLE TO
MOVE WE WANTED THEM TO BE
PREPARED AND TO BE READY TO
LEAVE THEIR HOMES WE WERE A
LITTLE BIT BETTER AT THIS TIME.
BUT WE KNOW THAT THERE WERE
STILL GLITCHES AND TO THAT. I
APPRECIATE ALL OF STEPPING IN
TO DO THESE AFTER REPORTS TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT WE DO BETTER
NEXT TIME. BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT
SAVES PROPERTY. LITTLE THINKING
LOTS OF PEOPLE LIKE TO. ABOUT
STAFFING. AND ABOUT OVER TIME.
FOR FIREFIGHTERS. AND I GET
THAT THERE'S PROBABLY I DON'T
KNOW ONE OR TWO WEEKS A YEAR OF
DOWNTIME NOW WHERE WE COULD BE
CONSCIENTIOUS ABOUT THAT. BUT
OTHER THAN THAT WHEN I HAVE
FIREFIGHTERS IN FRONT OF ME
SAYING THAT THE FIRST FORTY
EIGHT HOURS OF ONE OF THE
BIGGEST FIRES IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY. DIDN'T HAVE TIME OFF
THEY WORKED FORTY EIGHT HOURS
STRAIGHT AND THEY STAYED ON
THAT FIRE. FOR THE REMAINING
WEEKS BUT IT TOOK TO FINALLY
KNOCK IT DOWN. WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE POINTS
DOES TO OPERATING FIRE SERVICES
AT PER SESSION. FIRE FIVE
LEVELS WE FIRES HAVE FUN.
CHANGED IT IS A NEW NORM WE'VE
GOT A COUPLE OF CYCLES NOW OF
SAYING THESE FIRES ARE A NEW
NORMAL WE CAN'T FIGHT A NEW
NORMAL. WITH AN OUTDATED
STAFFING PLAN. AND SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT I KNOW YOU KNOW MY
VICE CHAIR AND I SHARE THIS AS
A HIGH PRIORITY WE NEED TO
CONTINUE. ELEVATE THAT TO
ENSURE THAT EACH OF YOUR
DEPARTMENTS IS ADEQUATELY
STAFFED UNIQUE PRESS. CONCERNS
ABOUT MOVING VOLUNTEER FIGHTERS
IN AND OUT OF THAT STAT. TO BE
ABLE TO KEEP UP UNITY SAFE MOST
BEING COMPLIANT WITH THE LOSS I
APPRECIATE BRINGING NOT FORWARD
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. AND THAT
BEING SAID. I APPRECIATE YOUR
FOR RECOMMENDATIONS AS WERE
VERY VERY CLEAR- I WOULD
WELCOME EACH OF YOU.
ADDITIONALLY TO SUBMIT TO US IN
WRITING. DREAM PLAN LET ANNA.
WHAT IS IT LIKE. HOW MUCH MORE.
HELP WITH WHAT OF OUR ALPHA FOR
ENGINE I KNOW DURING THE SALARY
I WAS OUT I DON'T LIKE TO SIT
AND WATCH THE NEWS THAT DOESN'T
LIKE A COULD USE OF MY TIME BUT
I ALSO LIKE JUST OFF THE OF
OKAY HOW I AT LEAST AND SHOWS A
SITE STARTED SHOWING UP AT AGE
TO SAY THANK YOU AND WENT INTO
A STATE AGING THAT I REPRESENT
AND THERE'S IN. THE BACK. OUT
WAS A ENOUGH TO GET OUT AT THE
TIME THE ENGINE WITH THE BACK.
SIX THE FIVE MOVING AT THE TIME
AND THEY WERE THE TO REMAIN
FIRE FOR AT STATION WE HAVE
LOVED TO HAVE THAT OUT IN THE
FIELD BUT THEY COULDN'T GET
THEIR- SO I GOT TO THINK ABOUT
THAT. WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE TO
YOU AND PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SUBMIT THIS TO US IN WRITING
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW MY
VICE CHAIR AND I ARE COMMITTED
TO CONTINUING TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION AND
CERTAINLY NOW IS WORK IN THESE.
CONVERSE WHICH WILL CONCLUDE IN
JUNE. BUT WE GET YOU. IS IT
BETTER TO TRY TO. A LITTLE BIT
MORE MONEY FOR PRE POSITIONING
WHAT IS ADDITIONAL AIR SUPPORT
LOOK LIKE THAT'S MOST HELPFUL
UNDER THE CURRENT CIRCUMSTANCES
ENGINES STAFF TIME WHEN I CAN
BE ABLE TO GUARANTEE WE CAN GET
ALL OF IT FOR YOU BUT YOU KNOW
THE OLD SAYING IF YOU DON'T ASK
YOU DON'T GET. SO FOR YOU TO
HAVE. ANY THAT. AND AGAIN. WITH
THE WITH THE MY TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF GRATITUDE THAT THAT I
CAN EXPRESS ON BEHALF OF MYSELF
MY VICE CHAIR AND THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE THANK
YOU FOR WHAT YOU DO FOR WHAT
YOU HAVE DONE FOR CONTINUING TO
PROVIDE LEADERSHIP AND WHAT IS
IN. INCREASING CHAU
CIRCUMSTANCE. AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY BUT PLEASE
DO STAY IN TOUCH LIKE IS THAT
BUDGET CYCLE ENDS IN JUNE WE
STILL GOT ASKS WE CAN GET ON
THE TABLE. ON HAVING SAID AND
VICE CHAIR HAVE. YES THANK YOU
AND I HAVE TO REITERATE YOU
KNOW THE HUMAN FACTOR I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT- WE'RE WE
ASK AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF OUR
FIREFIGHTERS AND I KNOW MANY
OF. YOU AND MANY OF THEM GO
THROUGH PTSD. ARE YOU DON'T
LIKE TO ADMIT IT BECAUSE YOU'RE
TOUGH GUYS BUT IN A WHICH IS
HUMAN BEINGS THIS IS TOUGH
STUFF WHEN YOU'RE WAY FROM YOUR
FAMILY. WHEN YOU HAVE TO PULL
OF. A BURNED BODY OUT OF A- A
HOME OR A CAR I MEAN THIS JUST
DOES HAVE AN IMPACT AND SO- I
THINK WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THE
HUMAN SIDE. OF THE GREAT WORK
YOU DO AS WELL AND SO I CAN
CORRECT IT IT'S SO CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT WE APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU DO. QUESTION SO. I IT THE
GOVERNOR IN THIS IN HIS BUT IN
THIS BUDGET DOES MAKE SOME SPUR
A COMMON I THINK WE PUT IN
ABOUT BILLION DOLLARS LAST YEAR
FOR MORE HELICOPTERS- AIR
SUPPORT EQUIPMENT AND I THINK
THIS YEAR THE GOVERNOR'S ALSO
PUT IN A REQUEST FOR SEVEN
HUNDRED MORE FIREFIGHTERS AND
I'M WONDERING. IF ONE OF YOU
COULD RESPOND IS THAT I MEAN
IT'S PROBABLY IS USE THERE'S
NEVER ENOUGH IS AT IT SHOULD
AND MEANINGFUL EFFORT IF YOU
COULD IF YOU COULD ASK FOR MORE
WERE SPECIFICALLY YOU ASK FOR.
THE TO. WELL FIRST OF ALL. HOME
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK THE
GOVERNOR FOR HIS COULD AS A
PERTAINS TO PUBLIC SAFE I WAS I
WON'T. DON'T WANT TO SAY IS A
DROP IN THE BUCKET. FOR LACK OF
A BETTER WORD THIS IS A DROP IN
THE BUCKET. YES MY UNDERSTAND
THIS STEP IS GOING TO BE A
MINIMUM OF FIVE YEARS. THIS IS
GONNA BE BRING IN A- OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE THEY WERE
PREVIOUSLY IN PRIOR TO THE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. AND THE
DOCTORS ARE A PLUS THE SYSTEM
BECAUSE THEY'RE GETTING
SIKORSKY HELICOPTERS IN THOSE
THE SAME CAR PRESENT LA COUNTY
GOT INITIALLY BUT THE MENTOR
CUNNINGHAM. THE LEASING. SO
THAT. I THE ONLY A LIKE WHAT
SAY A DISH TO THAT IS I MISSION
OR IS WE NOT GONNA BE A HIGH
PEOPLE FAST ENOUGH BUT THROUGH
WE ASK FROM INTO X. I DO A OR A
LOT TO IS THE THEY CAN ORDER.
THAT COULD STAFF LIKE SO OF THE
ENTITIES OF WANT TO. MORE THAN
ME TOO LATE OF I CAME AN EXAM
NOT UP IN YOU OF. MENTION IT
PLACE IT. DECEMBER PORTS IN THE
MEETING OF STAFFING BUT I'M AYE
TO PAR KNOWN ISSUE WE HAVE FAR
FOR SO WHY TO WORK OUT OF
EQUIPMENT. AND I KNOW FROM MY
ORGANS NINE THAT WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IN THIS SO IS THAT.
STEP IN AND SO INTO THE A IT'S
NOT JUST FOR US IT'S WE CAN.
THROUGHOUT THE CITY CALIFORNIA
BUT AT THE STATE SAVE TO.
DEPLOY MORE. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE BELIEVE THAT THERE'S A
ORDERS A LIKE THAN. OF THESE OF
LAKE. OF ORANGE COUNTY SANTA
GUARDS MUCH SOMETHING COME. FOR
A- WE'LL PUT MORE RESOURCES TO
THIS. HOW WAY AND EVEN THOUGH
I'M NOT MANAGED CHAIN HEREBY I
DO WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR IN MY
WORK TRY TO HOW MAKE SURE THE
BUDGET ALLOCATED ON TO WHERE WE
NEED AND WORK FOR. I LIKE
EVERYBODY BUT THERE'S CAMPARI
SET UP ASK YOU TO PAY TO THE
GUY WANTS CAL FOR. ADDING FOR
TO COME OF MOST THEY NEITHER
BUT RESTORED PER SE LEVEL THEY
NEED HIRE A VIGIL BROKEN. OF
BATES FIRE SERVICES WHICH OF
HER HERE TO ABOUT THE PROVIDER
AGENCY THAT SAYS. IN UPWARDS OF
EIGHTY OF THE RESOURCES AT PEAK
FARSI FOR THE FIRE. THERE. THAT
IS. CATERED FOR THE NEW SUPPORT
H. AS WELL. SO PART OF MY- DEBT.
TO EVERYBODY FROM SMALLER. WITH
ONE IN TWO ENGINE. TWO EIGHT.
WITH A HIGH AND EIGHTY SEVEN A
ONLY HAS LIKE THAT HUNDRED
SEVEN SO. LARGE AND SMALL
MUNICIPAL. THE A PIECE OF PIE.
TO BE ABLE TO PUT THEIR REESE.
AND SERVICE. AND REIMBURSED FOR
IT. THEY HAVE AN OFF. TO HIRE
FIRE. AT TO. STAFFING LEVELS AS
WELL BUT- THAT MONEY HAS TO BE
THERE OR THEY WON'T SEND THE
RESOURCES AND IF THEY CAN GET
REIMBURSED. AND FINALLY IN. US
NOT ONLY WILL ORDERING SO. CAN
OUT A FISH YEAH. BUT YEAH HAS
AND- THANK YOU. BUT THE
RESPONDING AGENCY LIKE. DOWNEY
ALWAYS THE OTHER. POLLS UP AND
DOWN THIS. AND PUT OUR- FIVE ON
THOSE. ENGINES MORE OF THOSE.
ENGINES IN THE- ALL DIFFERENT.
TYPES SINCE. THEN WE CAN MORE.
THERE'S WIRES. AS FAR AS IT SO.
WHAT'S THE NEED. TO I THINK THE
COMMON THEME IS THAT YOU NEED
AS MUCH HELP AS POSSIBLE THE
EARLIEST POSSIBE TIMES WHEN
YOU FIGHT THESE FIRES. ABOUT TO
IMPLEMENT THE I THINK IT'S
CALLED THE STOCK SYSTEM TO
REPLACE THE CURRENT ROB SINCE
I'M INTERESTED. BECAUSE
ACTIVATED IN MARCH I'M
WONDERING IF ANY OF YOU HAVE
ANY KIND OF ADVANCE. A LOOK AT
THE ADS SO THAT YOU CAN GIVE US
AN INDICATION WHETHER YOU THINK
THIS IS GOING TO- RESOLVE THE
PROBLEM OR DO WE NEED TO SORT
OF COME BACK IN A- YEARS WHEN
IT'S- PLUMMETED. FIND OUT
WHETHER TO. THE PROMISE IN THE
EXPECT THAT WE HAVE A- IS IT
ALREADY. OBSOLETE NOW HELP WELL
I THINK IT GOES BACK TO HER
PRESIDENT WHEN HE SPOKE ABOUT
FIRST MET. I MEAN THAT'S UP OF
COMMUNICATION SYSTEM THIS GO
SHE BY THE STATE. THAT AS FIRST
RESPONDERS WE DON'T HAVE INPUT
IN TO WITH A LOOKS LIKE THE
WEATHER NEGOTIATIONS ARE
FORTUNATELY IN LA COUNTY WE DO
BECAUSE WE HAD A GRANT FAR
PRIOR PRESIDENT SO WE WERE ABLE
TO DEAL WITH EIGHTEEN T. THAT'S
NOT EASY ORGANIZATION. WITHIN
ME TO SYSTEM. BUT I ROCKETS
ISN'T EXAMPLE I'M I'M A REASON
TO LIKE A ROACHES REGION TO AND
THAT WAS CHERYL ME I DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT IS IT WILL BE NICE TO
KNOW WHAT IT IS AND THEN IT
WILL BE NICE. IS THERE AN A
CONVEYOR ALSO. RECEIVE ARM.
REGIONAL OR- RISK RESOURCES
FROM ONE COUNTY LA QUE VINCE
SAID OF SANTA OBISPO THAT WE
WOULD HAVE SOME ANOTHER SOME IN.
AND PUT. I RECOMMEND SO I WE
COMMISSIONER. YOUR REGARDLESS
OF THE SYSTEM THAT'S IN PLACE
WHETHER IT'S ROSSER IROC THERE
ARE OTHER ISSUES IN ORDER FOR
THAT SYSTEM TO WORK THERE ARE
OTHER THINGS OUT THERE THAT
WE'VE BROUGHT UP TODAY- THAT.
HAVE PLACE FOR THAT SYSTEM TO
BE FULLY UTILIZED AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND THAT-
THE POINTS THAT WERE BROUGHT UP
BY. BUSBY I'D ABOUT HAVING THE
STAFFING BUT NOT HAVING THE
FIRE ENGINES I ROCKS ON FIX
THAT. THE APPLE I. UP. WHERE WE
DON'T STAFF YOU KNOW OUR OUR
PROP ON THIS AGENCY IS JUST
OPPOSITE WE HAVE PLENTY OF FIRE
ENGINES. BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE
STAFFING TO PUT ON. SO THOSE
ALSO NEED TO BE ADDRESSED IN
ORDER FOR THE SYSTEM ITSELF TO
BE FULLY SUCCESSFUL SO. CAN I
ADD TO THAT FOR YOU- IRAQ I'M
GLAD THEY'RE USING THAT NAME
BACK IN THE DAY THAT FOR THOSE
WAS THE BILL CARS THE CAMARO
IROC Z. WAS ONE OF THE CARS
EVER INTERNATIONAL RESEARCH
BINS. NEW ORDER THEM NEEDS TO
BE LOOKED AT THOSE CAR ANYTHING
AND EVERYTHING CO DEFIED. DIE
TO BIG FAT. THE RESPONSE TO
MAKE THE COOPERATION BETWEEN
THE LOCAL ENTITIES AS YOU'VE
HEARD IS ALREADY HAPPENING. A
PART OF THE SYSTEM TO BIFURCATE
CAL FIRE NO YES OF IT PIECES OF
THE ORDERING SYSTEM CAN BE MORE
EFFICIENT. THERE SHOULD NEVER
BE A TIME WHEN IN YEARS THAT.
EIGHT OUT AFTER ORDER WAS.
FILLED YOU IF I FIRE LIKE. SO
EVERY THAT SO MORE FOR IF WE
CAN LEGISLATIVELY TO FOR THE-
IN WAY. WHERE CA. AMONGST
AGENTS THIS CALL. AND ACTUALLY
PART OF THE AXIS WOULD. RIGHT
THANK YOU JOHN SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TEST APPRECIATE YOU MAKING A
TRIP TODAY. AND NOW WILL.
FORCED AND FEDERAL PURSE I'D
LIKE TO WELCOME JOE TILE DEPUTY.
OF PART AND PRO. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION AND BRIAN MARSHALL
CAL- YES FIRE AND RESCUE CHIEF.
ARGUMENT WHICH MICROPHONE WORK.
I THINK THAT. GERMAN FOR
JOINING US THIS AFTERNOON- I'M
DEPUTY DIRECTOR WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
SHARE THE STAFF OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
TODAY ON THIS IMPORTANCE OF.
BEING MUTILATED. YOU KNOW I
THINK IT IMPORTANT TO FIRST
TALK ABOUT TO WEAR FIRE IS
ASKING THE MUTUALLY THE MEN
OFFER RESOURCE TO THE MUTUALLY
JUST. AT CAL IS.
HEAVY
EQUIPMENT OPERATORS THAT WERE-
ADDED TO OUR BULLDOZERS TO
PROVIDE A TWENTY FOUR SEVEN A
BULLDOZER COVERAGE ACROSS THE
STATE WITH CAL FIRE- TO THE-
FIFTY NINE BULLDOZERS THAT WE
HAVE ACROSS THE STATE. IN
ADDITION A U. S. THERE A
RECORDING ASATRU AWARENESS AND
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET ADD AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTEEN INTEL
SPECIFIC INDIVIDUALS TO HELP
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. SO IT'S
IMPORTANT OF SAYING WHERE WE'VE
BEEN IN THIS DEVASTATION AND
ALL OF MY PARTNERS APPEARS THAT
WERE HERE BEFORE US ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AND EVERYTHING
THAT THEY WERE THEY WERE
MENTIONING. CALPERS PROPOSING
NOW TO REALLY DOUBLE DOWN AND-
MOVE FORWARD RELATED TO
RESOURCES- INTO THE FUTURE SO
IN THE CURRENT PROPOSED. BUDGET
MOVING FORWARD CAL FIRE THIS
LOOKED AT THE STAFFING. AND
WHILE WE'RE NOT SPECIFICALLY
ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL FIRE
ENGINES AT THIS TIME THE
STAFFING IS IMPORTANT IN ALL
EXPLAIN WHY YOU EARLY HEALTH
AND WELLNESS FIGHTERS ON THE
LINE FOR MULTIPLE HOURS WE HAVE
OUR SELVES. THE LOCAL STATE OR
FAT PARTNERS ARE FIREFIGHTERS
ARE FINE WELL THEN THEY SHOULD
AND WE NEED TO PROVIDE THE
HEALTH AND WELLNESS OF OUR
FIREFIGHTERS AND PROVIDE THEM
RELIEF. SO CAL FIRE IS GOING TO
BE POSING IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET- FOR AN ADDITIONAL
SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX
POSITIONS PHASED IN OVER FIVE
YEARS AS A FIRE FIGHTING
PERSONNEL THOSE ARE. PERSON
DISTRICT A LITTLE SUPPORT THE
YOU. DELAYED SYSTEM BUT THAT'S
JUST AS SAID EARLIER- WE ONE
ONE BUCKET THAT THE NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED OF THE SIX HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SEVEN FIVE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FIVE OF THOSE ARE
FIGHTING PERSONNEL OF IT WILL.
BE IN A FEW FANS ARE PREVENT UP
IS OUR FIRING ARE HELP BACK
BASES ARE ATTACK BASES AT TO BE
ABLE TO THE NET THIRTY SUPPORT
RELIEF TO OUR PER OF THAT.
CURRENTLY. HOW THE GROUP TO.
THE FIRE CHIEF TO SET ARE. THEY
WERE HERE EARLIER IN ACHIEVE
MARSHALL PREVIOUSLY HIS PRE
ROLE ARE TOWN. OF K. FIRE HAVE
SIX CAN OF THE CRISIS KERN
COUNTY COUNTY BEEN TRUE COUNTY
LA QUE. SAN OF COUNTY AND MARIN.
NOW WHEN WE LOOK AT. UPPER SIDE
TALKED ABOUT THE SIX HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SEVEN AND WE EVEN
TALK ABOUT THE THIRTEEN ENGINES
FROM LAST YEAR. THOSE COUNTRY
TO RECEIVE A PROPORTION CHAIR
OF THE FUNDING THAT'S AVAILABLE
THE HOPEFULLY THIS FIRE CHEESE
CAN SCAN SITTER- WHAT THEY WILL
DO THOSE FUNDS WHEN AMPLE.
THEIR BUDGETS- IT TAKES US.
GOING BACK TO WHAT CAL FIRE
HAS- PREVIOUSLY IN A CONTINUING
TO DO I AM PROUD TO SAY THE CAL
FIRE HAS THE LARGEST- FIGHTING
AVIATION PLEA IN THE WORLD- WE
ARE CURRENTLY STILL WITH UNITED
COAST GUARD UNITED STATES AIR
FORCE ON THE DELIVERY OF SEVEN
SIX ONE THIRTY HER. CRAFT BEER.
TANKERS I WAS PART NATIONAL
DEFENSE OTHER ACT. OF THAT
PROVIDES THE FUNDING FOR THE
MAINTENANCE AND SUPPORT AS WELL
THE PAINT AND THEN YOU ARE ALL
OF YOU IN THE ADMINISTRATION
SUPPORTED- THE OP CAN
AMENDMENTS OF THOSE GOING
FORWARD- WE- CRAFT THEY WILL. A
TOTAL SEVEN. OF THOUSAND GALLON
CAPE AIR TANKERS IT'LL BE FOR
ACROSS THE STATE FIVE OF THOSE
ANY ONE TIME TWO OF THOSE LEFT
IN RESERVE STATUS AND
MAINTENANCE STATUS ACROSS IS
LOCATED IN A RAMONA PASSER LOS
MY- SHE- AND THEN WE WILL. RE
OPEN THE FOR AIR BASE WITH BOTH
C. ONE THIRD TANK AND AIR TO
PLATFORM THERE. NOW IT HAS BEEN
A CHALLENGING PROCESS. WORKING
STATED WITH AGENCIES AND- THE
UNITED STATES AIR FORCE IS-
OWNERSHIP OF THE CONTRACT TO IN
A TO IMPLEMENT THE REGARD
DELIVERY SYSTEM AND- OTHER C.
ONE THIRTY AIRCRAFT AND THEY'RE
WORKING THROUGH THE PROCESS
THEY AWARDED. BOARD TO COLSON A-
BY DUE TO OUR- THEY HAD TO
SUSPEND- THAT- THAT CONTRACT
UNTIL THEY COULD REVIEW IT BUT
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO COME TO SOME
RESOLUTION HERE REAL SOON. WELL
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH. THE FOR.
THE ONE THIRTY AIR TANKER
FLYING STATE A CAP WITH ITS
PRIMARY LOOK CAN AMONG BY THE
TO THE. TWENTY AS WE ABOUT.
CLEAR IT WELL WE TALKED ABOUT
THE HELLO PRO AND WE THE
SUPPORT GIVEN OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION
ON THE REPLACEMENT OF THE U. H.
ONE H. HELICOPTERS TO THE S.
SEVENTY. HERE IS THE AND
BLACKROCK MODEL HELICOPTER THAT
MY PARTNER'S BEHIND US ARE
USING- CURRENTLY AND ARE ALSO
RECEIVING THOSE AIRCRAFT THERE
ARE GREAT UTILITY HELICOPTER.
WE WILL IN BE A OF NIGHTS WITH
LEASE FIVE OF THOSE CELICA
THOUGH ALL TWELVE OF THEM WILL
BE CAPABLE OF FLYING AT NIGHT-
AND WE SHOULD EXPECT TO SEE. WE
HAVE A SEVENTY AYE EATEN IN FOR
NOW FOR- IN INGLEWOOD COLORADO
GETTING IT'S AVIONICS ON- ONE
IS INTER TEXAS ENDED IN THE
OTHERS POLAND ACROSS THE- WE
WENT. EXPECT SELL IT. PRIVATE
EUROPEAN IT WILL GO TO A JUST
NORTH OF CHEAP SO THEN WILL
EXPECTED THE REST THEM EVERY
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS- OR OR
SOMEWHERE NEAR THERE AFTER. I
WANT TO GO BACK TO ONE THIRTY-
AIR TANKERS AND JUST BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO JUST
MENTION THIS MOMENT. IN THE
LAST BUDGET YOUR- SUPPORT OF
THE AVIATION FLEET. YOU ALSO
SUPPORTED A THREE YEAR CONTRACT
FOR A TRAINING PLATFORM. OF
LARGE AIR TANKER TRAINING
PLATFORM LOCATED WELL IN THAT
IT WAS GIVEN TO. CLOSE IT. GEN
AND IT'S GONNA TAKE A MOMENT
I'M- TO. TWO EIGHT NINE THE BEN
OF THE TREE THAT ARE. EVEN
THOUGH CO THIRD OR TANKERS. BUT
WHAT I WANT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DO IS AGAIN PUBLIC GIVE MY
THOUGHTS WITH THE CALLS AND
AVIATION AND- THE FLIGHT CREW
OF AIR TANKER ONE THIRTY FOR
THE CRIME IN AUSTRALIA
ASSISTING IN IN FOR. YEARS TAKE
A ONE THREE FOUR WAS A FLOP
CALIFORNIA WORKING CLOSELY WITH
COLSON AVIATION TO TRY TO FIND
A REPLACEMENT- TRACTOR PLATFORM
TO TEN YOU ARE TRAINING EFFORTS.
NOW ALL OF CRASH. TELL YOUR
BULLDOZER ARE P. HARM PEOPLE AS
WELL OF ALL OUR C<c.cyan> OPERATOR</c>
BUT THE LOW INFO LEVEL A REALLY
MAKE UP THE FIRE SERVE AND CAL
WE HAVE A GOLD THREE TO
MITIGATE OFF. AND FIVE PERSONAL
FIRES THE LAST THANK YES
EARLIER THERE ARE HOW OF THE OF
FIRE ACROSS CAL BUT EVERY A LOT
BECAUSE EVERYBODY THE IN THE
THAT ARE IN THE FOR RIGHT OUR-
JOB MAY. SPEYER WHENEVER HERE
ABOUT. WE HAVE A MAJOR ACCIDENT
DO TO OUR REACH AND RELY ON THE
ME AID SAYS TO SET CAL FIRE IN
ITS S. SIRI MISSION STATE WAS
HERE MISSION. I AM IT'S MY
EXPECTED SO WE'RE SUPPORT OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COOPERATED
REQUIRE IN THEIR FAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MIDSHIPS WELL. CAL
FIRE STOOD UP TO RAPIDLY TO AN-
TWO TO INCREASE DECREASE ITS-
ARE PRETTY RAPIDLY RAPPER WE
PARTICIPATE IN NUMBER OF A
PRIEST AGREE AND- AGREEMENTS
THAT WILL BE TALKED ABOUT HERE
SOON BY CHIEF MARSHALL. TO HELP
FACILITATE THE MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM AND WE APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT THAT ARE LOW IN FAT UP
HIS PRESENT AN- TO US FIGHTING
FIRES. I HEARD ABOUT OCT ABOUT
MY PRIVATE INSIGHT AND- HOW.
ORDERS OR PLACED IN I THINK YOU
HEARD A LOT ABOUT THAT. IN AND
SO. I WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT
THIS IS I MENTION IT. WE
CURRENTLY UTILIZE THE RESOURCE
ORDERING STATUS SYSTEM ALSO
KNOWN AS ROSS. THE RAS SYSTEM
IS TURNED OFF AT MIDNIGHT ON
MARCH FIFTH. THE INTER AGENCY
RESOURCE- ORDERING CAPABILITY
IROC I WILL BE OUT TURNED ON IN
CALIFORNIA SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
MARCH ELEVENTH AND MARCH
THIRTEENTH IT IS A FEDERAL
SYSTEM THAT LEAVES US ABOUT
SEVEN DAYS OF A BLACKOUT
ORDERING SYSTEM AND I'LL BE
HONEST WITH YOU I HAVE MY
FINGERS CROSSED THAT WE HAVE NO
MAJOR WHAT THE CROSS STATE K.
BUT- RK. EARS ARE PRIMARY THE
SAFETY AND POINTS ARE THIS
CENTER SHOULD HAVE CONTINUITY
OF OP PLAN AND THOSE RUSH USER
SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT GOING
BACK TO A UTILIZING THEIR TO
CUT PLANS TO OVERCOME THIS
ISSUE AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND
AGAIN HOPE OR NO MAJOR ISSUES
NOW. TALK ABOUT IRAQ GETTING
TURNED BACK ON THERE ARE
CONCERNS AND WE HAVE EXPRESSED
THOSE CONCERNS THOSE CONCERNS
ARE THAT- WHEN IT GETS TURNED
BACK ON WE WILL NOT WE BUT
GLOBALLY THE IROC SYSTEM WILL
NOT TRAINED ANYBODY ON HOW TO
USE AT THE MOMENT THAT IT'S AND
ON THERE ARE FOR BOTTLES OF
TRAINING THERE ARE- MODULE THAT
HAVE HELPED BY THE- TEAM IN
THERE IS THE FOURTH Mà. CAN.
AND WE WILL THAT OUT THERE OVER
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED ROSH AND-
RIGHT NOW. AND WE EXPECT IRA
YOU TO BE. VERY SIMILAR IN
NATURE EDIT SAVE IRA. IS GONNA
IS GOING TO WORK ANY THAN ROSS
I DON'T KNOW THAT ANSWER TODAY
PARTIALLY BECAUSE I HAVEN'T
SEEN IT EITHER I HAVEN'T SEEN
THE TRAINING MODULES BUT I WANT
YOU TO THINK ABOUT. AS WELL WE
TALK ABOUT IT AND IT WAS
EARLIER. SO ROD. IS A- WHAT.
WHEN IT WAS BILL OVER A DECADE
A- HAD NO CAL. VOICE ON IT. I
AT LEAST FROM QUE FIRES FOR. WE
MADE SURE THAT WE HAD A
CALIFORNIA VOICE ON THE IRA
GROUP- TO- AS AS A SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERT TO AT LEAST BE
ABLE TO RELAY INFORMATION BACK
AND FORTH. BUT WHETHER IT'S
ROSSER IRONIC. IT'S A PIECE OF
SOFTWARE. IN YOU HAVE TO HAVE
THE APPROPRIATE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE AND THE RIGHT PEOPLE TO
BE ABLE TO INPUT THE ORDER INTO
A PIECE OF SOFTWARE AND HAVE
SOMEBODY AT THE OTHER END WHO
CAN EXTRACT THE ORDER OF THE
PIECE OF SOFTWARE SO THE
QUESTION IS RIDLEY WHETHER ROSS
OR IRAQ IS BROKEN I WOULD SAY.
NO THE PROCESS IS IN A- THE
PROCESS IS CHALLENGED IN NEEDS
TO BE IMPROVED AND WE CAN
APPROVE THAT THROUGH. THROUGH
CONSIDERATION OF STAFFING-
STAFFING OF AS YOU HEARD
EARLIER STAFFING OF OUR
DISPATCH CENTERS WHO ARE
CONCURRENTLY RECEIVING ORDERS
FROM THE FIELD WHAT THE SAME
TIME TAKING NINE ONE ONE CALLS.
FROM PEOPLE WHO WERE TRAPPED OR
WERE SEEKING SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES. NOW THEY ARE PLACING
THERE'S ORDERS ORDERS ARE GOING
TO OPERATIONAL CENTERS ON IN
REDDING ONE AND RIVERSIDE WHERE
THEY ARE CO LOCATED BETWEEN-
CAL FIRE HELLO YES AND FEDERAL
RESOURCES- AND OR- STAFF.
SOMETIME THERE'S A PLACE OUT
AND OP AREAS THAT ALSO HAVE.
GOING ON SO YOU WERE INJURED BY.
BY NOW WERE ABLE TO PUT AN
EXTRA. INFORMATION OUT OF WHAT
ONE BE A- SO I WOULDN'T THIS IS
OUR- EVERYBODY. I'M SURE HAS AS
PART OF COMPANY OF OP. BUT IT
IS IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER AND
HAVE A PLAN AND EXERCISE THAT
PLAN TO ENSURE THAT YOUR WHEN
YOU HAVE A MAJOR INSTEAD OF ANY
ALL HAZARD OR IS TIED. THAT YOU
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TRY TO
FIND A WAY TO GET YOUR- LOW.
AND OFF COMMAND. IN AN EXPANDED
CENTER WHERE YOU'RE- NINE ONE.
FOR ALL YOUR OTHER INCIDENTS
PROTECTING EVERY YEAR CAN. ARE
STILL THERE TO BE RUN. IF THAT
MAKES SENSE. WE HAVE PARTNERED
WITH CALLOW YES IN OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS FOR MANY YEARS TO USE
THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM AND IT'S
A GOOD SYSTEM BUT IT IS A
STRANGE SYSTEM THAT BEING SAID
WE HAVE EXPERIENCED THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE FIRES ON A RECORDED
HISTORY IF THE CLASS ENGINE OF
SPREAD ACTIVE OVERGROWN
PROLONGED DROUGHT THAT WOULD
STILL BE COVERING FROM- AS WELL
AS THE- RECENT. NUMBER WHILE
THERE'S ALSO. THIS. WORK
TOGETHER THROUGH FIRE SCOPE AND
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS TO DO THAT-
ONE OTHER ITEM- MADAM VICE
CHAIR YOU ASKED SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT SITUATIONAL AWARENESS AND
WHERE WE WERE ON THAT I'LL JUST
ADDRESS THAT AND SHE- FROM TWO
WORKING CLOSELY I'M GOING TO
DEATH BUT WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD
WE REALIZE THEIR ASSETS OF THE-
ON STAFF AND YOU NINE IT'S AN
AERIAL PLATFORM REMOTE SERVERS
A STAFF SEE TWELVE SIX SINCE
TYPE AIRCRAFT THAT IS ABLE TO
PUT. UP A REAL TIME DATA ONCE
WE CAN GET THAT AIRCRAFT UP
OVER AN INCIDENT AND THEN THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD IS
PARTICIPATING WHAT THEY CALL
FIRE GUARD WHICH UTILIZING A
REMOTE SENSORS FROM CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION DE CLASSIFYING THAT
MAKING IT A BIT. TO TIRES IS
DEFINITELY. SEVEN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THIS LAST YEAR YOU
ALSO OFFERED AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO GO INTO A INNOVATIVE
PROCUREMENT SPRINT TO PROCESS-
AS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER- WERE ABLE TO
WORK WITH TECHNIQUES OF FIRE
PROTECTION- THAT RESOURCE IT'S
WORKED WELL FOR THE PROOF OF
CONCEPT WERE NOW CONSIDERING
OUR OPTIONS MOVING LONG TERM.
SAID EARLIER AND TELLS THE-
STOP BEING THERE. I THE CURRENT
YEAR A HUNDRED ADDITIONAL- FIRE
VALIDATION CAMERAS ON THE
RECALL THE FIRE DETECTION
CAMERA AT THIS POINT- WERE-
OFFERED- BEEP PLACED ON VARIOUS
MOUNTAIN TOPS IN THE COURSE WE
UTILIZE OUR PRO LONG ARE BEING
THE CW AND IS WITH- AND TELL.
CAPABILITIES TO ASSIST US IN
THOSE NEEDS AS WELL SO WITH
THAT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND LOOK FORWARD ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS THAT TIME. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR SMITH
BODIES CHAIRED JACKSON SENATORS
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
ON IN- SOME OF THE UNIQUENESS
SERVE OUR MUTUAL AID SYSTEM THE
COLLABORATION- INITIATIVES THAT
WE HAVE. MARSHALL I'M A THIRTY
THREE YEAR VETERAN PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTER I SPENT THE LAST
THIRTY TWO YEARS IN KERN
COUNTY- SEVEN YEARS AS THE FIRE
CHIEF WORKING WITH CAL FIRE AND
ALL OF MY PARTNERS BEHIND ME
ANY YEAR AGO I WAS OFF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME IN THE
STATE'S FIRE RESCUE MUTUAL IT
SYSTEM. AND IT'S THE SYSTEM I
BELIEVE IN IS A FIREFIGHTER I
USED IT AS A FIRE CHIEF MIKE
FOR HELP. AND I KNOW WHAT THE
SYSTEM IS. THERE'S NO OTHER
LEGISLATIVE BODY TALKING ABOUT
A MUTUAL AID SYSTEM LIKE WE
HAVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. IT IS
ROBUST. WORKS AND LET ME STRESS
SOMETHING IT'S ALL HAZARD I
KNOW THE FOCUS TODAY IS ON
WILDFIRE BUT WE USE THE SAME
SYSTEM LAST SUMMER WHEN THERE
WAS AN EARTHQUAKE IN ITS CREST.
THE MUTUAL SYSTEM IS THE NINE
HELP OUR NEIGHBORS IN
CALIFORNIA IS A BIG STATE AND
WE MOVE RESOURCES ALL OVER THE-
SO TO ME TALK ABOUT SORT OF THE-
AIDS OF OUR- NHà FIRE RESCUE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM. MANY OF THE
DISASTERS AND EVENTS- WE LEARN
FROM. AND IF YOU IF YOU DON'T
LEARN FROM YOUR BOUNDARY PETE
HISTORY. AND WE DO AFTER
ACTIONS AFTER THESE LARGE
EVENTS BUT WE SEE. THREE FOCUS
AREAS THAT CAL O. S. ON OUR
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM COLLABORATION
PREPARATION AND TECHNOLOGY.
COLLABORATION YOU'VE SAW A WIDE
VARIETY OF INDIVIDUALS FIRE
CHIEFS FIRE CAPTAIN FROM
AGENCIES ALL OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS ARE IN HERE BUT FOR
SERVICE PARK SERVICE BUREAU OF
LAND MANAGEMENT. EVEN OUR
TRIBAL PARTNERS THAT WE WORK
WITH AND OF COURSE THE GREAT
COLLABORATION WITH CAL FIRE. WE
ALL BRING RESOURCES TO THE
TABLE. AND WE ALL NEED THOSE
RESOURCES AT SOMETIMES. AND AS
SAID OFTEN DURING THOSE
SAPONINS TESTIMONY RESOURCES
NEED TO GET THEIR QUICK THEY
NEED TO BE ORDER QUICKLY THE
INCIDENT NEEDS TO BE ORGANIZED
BUT IT'S A COLLABORATION.
PREPARATION PRE POSITIONING HAS
BEEN MENTIONED I MANAGE THE PRE
POSITIONING PROGRAM AND WE PRE
POSITIONED RESOURCES ALL OVER
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WITH
PRE POSITIONED HUNDREDS OF
TIMES. THERE'S ONLY BEEN TO
DIALS A PRE POSITIONED
RESOURCES ARE RESOURCE REQUEST
OVER THE COURSE OF THE PROGRAM.
BUT THAT HAS LED TO SMALLER
FIRES THAT YOU NEVER HEAR ABOUT.
DURING LAST TALK POWER SHUT OFF
IN EXTREME FIRE WEATHER EVENT
AT ANY GIVEN TIME THERE WERE
SIXTY FOUR PRE POSITIONED
STRIKE TEAMS ARE HELICOPTERS
BULLDOZERS EVER THE NEED WAS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT
IS A RESOURCE WENT OF FIRES WE
WERE BACK FELONIES RESOURCES.
DURATION IS ONE OF THE KEY
FACTORS AND THEN TECHNOLOGY I
CAN'T I CAN'T STRESS TECHNOLOGY
ENOUGH IT WAS TALKED ABOUT BY.
EVERYBODY WHO'S BEEN BEFORE YOU
TODAY AND I WILL TALK ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY HE- HOW WE USE TO
OUR G. TO VALIDATE FIRES THE
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS AND THE
RESPONSE. THAT HOME EVERY DAY
IN CALIFORNIA. SO LET ME GIVE
YOU SOME SPECIFICS ABOUT OUR
CALIFORNIA'S MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
AND HOW IT OPERATES WANT TO
GIVE YOU SOME BACKGROUND INTO A
SYSTEM THAT WAS BORN OUT OF
DISASTERS. AND EXPANDED INTO
THIS ALL HAZARD CAPABILITY. WE
HAVE THOUSANDS OF MUTUAL AID
ASSETS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOT ONLY FIRE
ENGINES AND FIREFIGHTERS BUT WE
HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT MUTUAL AID
WE HAVE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
MUTUAL AID WE HAVE ALL OF THESE
ASSETS. AND WE HAVE PLANS IN
AGREEMENTS. THE MASTER MUTUAL
AID AGREEMENT WHICH IS SIGNED
BY EVERYBODY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LITERARY EVERY THE A
SIGNED THAT AGREEMENT.
FOUNDATION FOR MUTUAL AID
OPERATE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA FIRE
SERVICE AND RESCUE EMERGENCY
MUTUALLY POWELL PLAN THAT
EXISTS TODAY IS A COMPONENT OF
THAT MASTER MUTUAL AREEMENT
AND THE STATE'S EMERGENCY. A
PLAN. THESE WERE ADOPTED IN THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES CALIFORNIA'S
BEEN A PROGRESSIVE STATE OF
COURSE WE SEE MORE DISASTERS
THAN ANYBODY BUT THE PLAN IS
BASED ON THE CONCEPT OF
NEIGHBOR HELPING NEIGHBOR.
GOING BACK AND FORTH
JURISDICTIONAL BOUNDARIES THEY
ONLY EXIST ON A MAP THEY DON'T
EXIST IN MUTUAL AID EVERYBODY
HELPS EVERYBODY. AND SOMETIMES
WE DO IT FOR VERY MASTER MUTUAL
AID WITH NO EXPECTATION OF
REIMBURSEMENT. LET ME GO INTO
THAT JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE IN
DEPTH DURING THE RIDGE CREST
EARTH QUAKE WE CALLED FIRE
CHIEF THAT WERE BEHIND US THAT
ARE SITTING BEHIND US TODAY AND
ASK THEM TO SEPARATE PURSES
FROM AID TO CITY OF RIDGECREST
WITH NO EXPECTATION A
REIMBURSEMENT. THERE WAS NO
HESITATION THAT'S THE SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA. THE
MASTER MUTUAL AID AGREEMENT AND
STANDARDIZE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM ARE DESIGNED
AND LEVERAGE TO RESPOND ALL
HAZARDS I CANNOT STRESS THAT
ENOUGH EVEN THE CAMP FIRE WHICH
BURNED. SIGNIFICANT HOMESLOSS
OF LIFE THERE WAS STILL
RECOVERY EFFORT AFTER THAT AND
THAT'S WHERE THE URBAN SEARCH
AND RESCUE SYSTEM RESPONDED. TO
THIS ALL HAZARD MUTUAL AID PLAN.
AND AGAIN LAW ENFORCEMENT
HOMELAND SECURITY FIRE AND
RESCUE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
EMERGENCY MEDICAL EVEN PUBLIC
WORKS WE ALL ARE RESPONDING IN
SUPPORT OF MUTUAL AID. SO HOW
DOES THIS WORK. THE WRITTEN
REQUEST FOR RESOURCES FOR
RESPONSE TO AN EMERGENCY THAT
IS A BE ON THE ABILITY OF A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN IT TO YOU
TO CONTROL ARE INITIATED
THROUGH THE- THEM. GOVERNMENTS
ARE SET UP. TO RESPOND TO THE
DAY TODAY. BUT WHEN YOU END UP
WITH A LOOSELY FIRE A CAMPFIRE.
THAT'S BEYOND NORMAL DAY TO DAY.
REQUESTS ARE FILLED BY THE
CLOSEST AVAILABLE RESOURCES.
REMEMBER CALIFORNIA'S BIG STATE
SO IF YOU HAVE THE CAMP FIRE
BURNING IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
THERE MAY BE RESOURCES COMING
OUT OF SAN DIEGO. MULTIPLE
FIRES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
CHALLENGED THE SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA AGAIN IS A BIG STATE.
OUR FIRE ENGINES ARE WATER
TENDERS TO THE STATE MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM ARE THE MOST UTILIZE
RESOURCES IN MUTUAL AID. WATER
TENDERS ARE CAPABLE OF BRINGING-THAT WATER TO THE SCENE BECAUSE
THESE FIRES ARE OCCURRING IN
RULE AREAS AND AS WE FACE LAST
SUMMER THE POWER WAS SHUT OFF
WHICH AFFECTED OUR WATER SUPPLY.
FIRE ENGINES THERE IN EVERY
FIRE STATION THERE'S MULTIPLE
TYPES AND THEY'RE RESPONDING TO
ASSIST ANSWERING THE CALL OF
HELP. THE REQUESTING AN ANTI
SHOULD MAKE MAXIMUM USE OF THE
EQUIPMENT FACILITIES AND
SERVICES DURING THE PERIOD OF
EMERGENCY. THE RECORDING
ENTITIES HELP OFFSET THE
EXTREME BURDEN AS FAR UNITS
COME INTO- THE EMERGENCY. BUT
WITH. FIRE AGENCIES LIKE CAL
FIRE IN OUR LARGER FIRE
AGENCIES THEY HAVE THE SUPPORT
TO SUPPORT THE MUTUAL AID
RESOURCES THAT CUT. AND ONCE
THE INCIDENT IS MITIGATED THOSE
MUTUAL AID RESOURCES ARE
RELEASED. FEDERAL FIRE
SUPPRESSION RESOURCES THEIR
CONTRACTORS SUBCONTRACTORS ARE
NOT PART OF THE MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM THOUGH. THOSE RESOURCES
ARE CALLED UP THROUGH DIFFERENT
MEANS SUCH AS THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE COMPACT
OR EMAIL CAN ALL TALK ABOUT IT.
SCHOOL OPERATE. HELLO YES FIRE
AND RESCUE. WE'RE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE COORDINATION AND
IMPLEMENTATION THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE RESCUE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM.
AS MENTIONED THE STATE'S BROKEN
INTO SIX DIFFERENT MUTUAL AID
RESERVE REGION'S. I AM INVOLVES
MORE THAN ONE THOUSAND FIRE
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. PAID
PROFESSIONAL FIRE DEPARTMENTS
VOLUNTEER FIRE DEPARTMENTS
WHICH MAKE UP OVER 30% OF OUR
FIRE FIGHTING FORCE IN
COMBINATION FIRE DEPARTMENTS
WHICH HAVE VOLUNTEERS AND PAID
FIREFIGHTERS. AND THE PLEDGE TO
ASSIST WITH THE MUTUAL AID TO
THE MOBILIZATION THEIR
RESOURCES. THE FIERY USED
TOGETHER WITH CARILLO YES OWN
MORE THAN SIX THOUSAND ALL
RESPIRE ENGINES. CALORIE US
PROVIDES FIRE ENGINES ALSO. WE
GIVE FIRE ENGINES THROUGH AN
AGREEMENT TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FIRE DEPARTMENTS AND WHEN WE
TALKED THIS AFTERNOON WITH MY
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUES TALK THEY
TALKED ABOUT NEEDING MORE FIRE
ENGINES. ME TELL YOU WHAT TYPE
THREE FIRE ENGINES WHICH ARE
EXPANSION FIRE ENGINES TO THE
YES FLEET ARE UNDER
CONSTRUCTION RIGHT NOW TO HAVE
JUST ARRIVED IN SAN BRUNO.
SEVENTY NOT TIED SIX FIRE
ENGINES ARE UNDER CONSTRUCTION
AT THIS TIME. I AM WILL BE IN
SERVICE. IN CALIFORNIA BEFORE
THE END OF THE YEAR. THOSE TYPE
SIX FIRE ENGINES ARE ALSO ALL
HAZARD. AT ANY GIVEN TIME THERE
ARE APPROXIMATELY ONE THOUSAND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FIRE ENGINES
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE RESCUE MUTUAL
AID SYSTEM. THE FIVE FIVE
HUNDRED FIRE ENGINES CAN BE
MOBILIZED ANYWHERE WITHIN
CALIFORNIA WITH FIRST TWELVE TO
TWENTY FOUR HOURS. THE NEXT
FIVE UPPER FIRE ENGINES CAN BE
MOBILIZED ANYWHERE IN
CALIFORNIA WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
TO THIRTY SIX HOURS. AND I'VE
BEEN ON THOSE FIRE ENGINES AS A
FIREFIGHTER I RESPONDED TO THE
CEDAR FIRE IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE AND- SAN DIEGO. AND I
COULD TELL YOU THE CONFERENCE
CALLS THAT WERE OCCURRING IS
THAT FIRE WAS BURNING AND
BURNING HOUSES. AND DESTROYING
LIVES WAS SEND EVERYTHING YOU
CAN AND THE CALIFORNIA FIRES
SERVICE. THEY ANSWERED THAT
CALL. FIRE ENGINES WERE ON THE
ROAD RESPONDING. YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY ABOUT THE EXPERIENCES IN
YOUR DISTRICT HOW THE
CALIFORNIA'S MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
AND AGAIN BOTH BAR- AND RESCUE
LAW ENFORCEMENT HOMELAND
SECURITY EMS HAVE BEEN PUT TO
DEATH PUT TO THE TEST. IN
SEVENTEEN AFTER THE SUMMER
FIRES ALONG THE CALIFORNIA
OREGON BORDER IN IN THE CENTRAL
PART OF OUR STATE. OVER ONE
AND- IS BROKE OUT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. ALL THE WAY FROM
THE NORTH TO THE SOUTH OVER
FOUR HUNDRED LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FIRE DEPARTMENTS FROM AROUND
THE STATE WERE MOBILIZED. OVER
TWO HUNDRED FIRE ENGINES FROM
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA RESPONDED
TO OUR CALLS FOR ASSISTANCE.
EVEN FIREFIGHTERS FROM US
AUSTRALIA. AND WE RECIPROCATE
WITH THAT HELP AS CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTERS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ARE IN AUSTRALIA
RIGHT NOW. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN CARILLO YES
COORDINATED ALMOST THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND RESOURCES THROUGH OUR
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM. TO BATTLE
THE JULY FIRE CAR MENDOCINO.
EIGHTY FIRE ENGINES WERE
BROUGHT IN FROM OUT OF STATE
FOR THAT OF AN- FOR THE NUMBER
NOVEMBER FIRES. CAMP HILL AND
LOOSELY WHICH ARE TALKED ABOUT
TODAY THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
ENGINES WERE BROUGHT IN TO THE
STATE. AND AGAIN IT TAKES TIME
TO GET THOSE RESOURCES IN. BUT
ONE KEY POINT. THESE FIRES ARE
BURNING NOW WHAT'S GOOD TO BE
BURNING IT OUR- WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE NOBODY HAS
A CRYSTAL BALL IN THE
CALIFORNIA FIRES THIS. THESE
FIRE ENGINES ARE COMING IN.
SOME OF THEM GO DIRECTLY TO THE
FIRE SUMMER STAGE SO WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL SURGE CAPACITY
SHOULD MORE FIRES BREAK OUT.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS CAL
FIRE TESTED. WAS MORE THAN A
NORMAL FIRE YEAR. HOW EVER IN
SOUTHERN AND NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE SAW A FLURRY OF
FIRE ACTIVITY IN OCTOBER. AND
AGAIN POWER SHUT OFF DO NOT
HAPPEN FIRST IT'S THE FIRE
WEATHER OF THAT THAT DRIVES
POWER SHOW OFFS AND NEARLY AT
THE ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WAS IN A FIRE WEATHER OF. AS
MENTIONED THE SAP WHICH FIRE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
TWENTY FIVE STRUCTURES AND LEAD
TO ONE CIVILIAN FATALITY. EIGHT
OF OUR FIRES WERE INJURED. THE
TECH FIRE IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FOUR THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
FIFTEEN ACRES TWENTY TWO
STRUCTURES DESTROYED THE EASY
FIVE ARE INVENTOR A- EIGHTEEN
HER ACRES BURNED AND THREATEN
THE RONALD REAGAN LIBRARY. AND
THEN THEY CAN KATE FIRE AND
SONOMA COUNTY. SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND ACRES THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR STRUCTURES. WE
BEGAN AUGMENTING OUR- PROCESS
OF ORDERING RESOURCES. PRE
POSITIONING IS AN AMAZING
PROGRAM. WE'RE NOT ONLY DOING
IT WIN MORE CALL BY A FIRE
DEPARTMENT OR AN OPERATIONAL
AREA WE'RE LEANING FORWARD
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE WEATHER
OUT IN FRONT OF US. WE HAVE
EXCELLENT TECHNOLOGY THAT TELLS
US WHAT THE WEATHER'S GOING TO
BE AND WE WORK WITH FIRE
DEPARTMENTS TO PRE POSITION
THESE RESOURCES IT ALLOWS FOR
RAPID DEPLOYMENT OF THESE FIRE
ASSETS WHEN THE FIRE SMALL. AS
A PROFESSIONAL OUR FIGHTERS IN
THE ROM CAN ATTEST IF YOU KEEP
THE FIRE SMALL IT'S EASIER TO
CONTAINED. THE SOBRE ALMOST
FIRE IN MONTEREY COUNTY. IT WAS
SO BIG IT BURNED FROM JULY TO
OCTOBER. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. HELLO IS FILLED
280-008-0090 SIX FIRE AND
RESCUE MUTUAL AID REQUEST
EXCUSE ME THAT WAS TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. ONLY FIVE THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THREE WERE IN
NINETEEN. AND A LOT OF THAT WAS
DUE TO THE PRE POSITIONING
SUCCESS. AS I MENTIONED
REPOSITIONING IS PART OF OUR
PREPARATION IT BOLSTERS THE
LOCAL RESPONSE AND ANY FIRE
CHIEF THAT'S USING THIS PROGRAM
THEY KNOW THE VALUE OF IT.
WE'RE NOT ONLY VOWED PRE
POSITIONING FIRE ENGINES WERE
PRE POSITIONING HELICOPTERS
HAND CREWS BULLDOZERS AND WE DO
IT ALSO FOR THE MUD AND DEBRIS
YOU FLOWS THAT OCCUR. AFTER THE
FIRES THANK GOODNESS WE HAVEN'T
HAD EXTREME WINTER STORMS THIS
YEAR WITH ALL OF THE LANDS
BURNED IN CALIFORNIA. THIS PRE
POSITIONING ALLOW QUICK
REACTION TIMES TO AN INCIDENT
IT MITIGATES THE DISASTER TO
REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
CATASTROPHIC FIRE CONDITIONS.
AND I'LL TELL YOU THIS. I
RECEIVED THE LETTERS I'VE HAD
THE PHONE CALLS THE REASSURANCE
TO THE COMMUNITY TO SEE THOSE
EXTRA FIRE ENGINES IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES KNOWING THAT
THEY'RE AVAILABLE FOR A QUICK
RESPONSE ISRAEL ASSURING TO THE
COMMUNITY. PREPOSITIONING WE
USE THE FIRE WEATHER THE FIRE
DANGER AND FUELS LEVEL AND THE
INTELLIGENCE THAT WE KNOW. ONE
THING WE KNOW THERE'S MICRO
COMMUNITY CLIENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT WE PRISON PRE POSITIONED
MOST IS SANTA BARBARA COUNTY.
BECAUSE SANTA BARBARA HAS A
CONDITION CALLED SUNDOWNERS.
AND WE WORK WITH SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY TO PRE POSITIONED
RESOURCES ALMOST ON A REGULAR
BASIS. SINCE JULY OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN CALLOW YES IS
AT TWO HUNDRED AND THREE PRE
POSITION APPROVALS AND TO NILES.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT PRE POSITION REQUEST. AND
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
APPROVED PRE POSITION REQUEST.
SO LET ME TALK ABOUT TECHNOLOGY.
THERE ARE CHALLENGES AND GAPS
THAT EXIST IN OUR CURRENT
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM BUT WE ACT
HELLO YES SIR JUST IN
ADDRESSING THESE CHALLENGES
WITH A NUMBER OF INITIATIVES
PROGRAMS AND NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
THESE CHALLENGES TO MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM ARE THE DIRECT RESULT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE DIET
DOWNSIZING A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FIRE DEPARTMENTS AS THE RESULT
OF THE TWO THOUSAND NINE
RECESSION. SO WE'RE
IMPLEMENTING A NUMBER OF NEW
PROGRAMS. AGAIN THE PRE
POSITIONING OF RESOURCES IN THE
EVENT OF PROJECTED WHETHER.
USING TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS SCOUT
TO IMPROVE OUR SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS IN YES NO FIREFIGHTER
RESPONDING FROM OUTSIDE THEIR
JURISDICTION TO HELP ANOTHER
COMMUNITY SHOULD BE IN THE
DARK. SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
SHOULD COME TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY. WE'RE USING A FIRE
INTEGRATED REAL TIME
INTELLIGENCE PILOT PROGRAM IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. IT'S REAL
TIME DATA FROM AN AIRCRAFT.
THAT IS LAUNCHED ON INITIAL
ATTACK AND I CAN TELL YOU WHEN
THE MARIE A FIRE WAS BURNING IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA VENTURA WE
WERE GETTING REAL TIME DATA.
AND HAVING REAL TIME DATA ON
WHAT THE FIRE WAS DOING. THERE
WAS AN F. MAC WHICH IS A FIRE
MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE GRANT.
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
PAYS 75% BY HAVING THAT REAL
TIME DATA WE'RE ABLE TO JUST
TELL OUR STORY TO FEMA. AND GET
APPROVALS OF THESE F. MAX WHICH
HELP LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM
BEARING COST OF FIRES. A NEW
PILOT PROGRAM IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN REGION ONE LOS
ANGELES. WE ARE USING A PROGRAM
THAT WAS MITCHELL. EXCUSE ME
WERE FIRED HIS PICK UP THE
PHONE AND CALL THEIR
NEIGHBORING FIRE DEPARTMENT.
THE ORANGE COUNTY PART OF JESUS
TOLD ME I HAVE EIGHTY FIRE
ENGINES. I WILL SEND FORTY PICK
UP THE PHONE AND CALL ME WE'VE
INITIATED THIS PROGRAM IT'S A
PILOT PROGRAM AND IT'S UNDER.
UNDER A REAL WORLD TEST IN
pABLE TO MOVE FIRE ENGINES. AND
HELICOPTERS TO RAPIDLY
SPREADING WILDLAND FIRE SANTA
ANA DRIVEN WIND DRIVEN FIRES
ARE BURNING STRUCTURES BY
PICKING UP THE PHONE. BUT WE
STILL PUT IT IN THE SYSTEM
BECAUSE EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO KNOW WHAT RESOURCES
ARE AVAILABLE. WE'RE ALSO
WORKING ON A MUTUAL AID
REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FIRE DEPARTMENTS
WHEN THEY SEND THEIR
FIREFIGHTERS OUT THE DOOR
THEY'RE BEARING THE COST TO PAY
THOSE FIREFIGHTERS UNTIL THE
REIMBURSEMENT GETS. BACK IN THE
BANK WE'RE WORKING ON THIS
PROGRAM WHICH WILL HELP TO
SPEED UP REIMBURSEMENT AND ALSO
MAINTAIN AN INVENTORY OF
RESOURCES AVAILABLE IN THE
STATE. I AM PROUD TO SAY AND
THE CURRENT BUDGET. WE HAVE
INTEL MOBILIZATION DIVISION
THAT'S BEING BUILT AT- YES FIRE
AND RESCUE RIGHT NOW. IT'LL
PROVIDE REAL TIME DATA IN REAL
TIME MOBILIZATION OF RESOURCES.
WHERE THE PROBLEM OF REPEAT
REGION STAFFING WAS MENTIONED
WE WILL HAVE YES FIRE AND
RESCUE DISPATCHERS ADDO YES
HEADQUARTERS THAT WILL HELP TO
MOBILIZE THESE RESOURCES. MORE
STAFFING IS PROPOSED IN THE
UPCOMING BUDGET TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE THE RESOURCES THE STAFFING
NECESSARY IN THIS INTEL
MOBILIZATION CENTER. WE ARE IN
DISCUSSIONS RIGHT NOW TO HAVE A
MUTUAL AID INTERCOM SYSTEM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AS
MENTIONED ROSS IS SOMEWHAT
STIFLING TO THE ORDERING
PROCESS AGING GETTING ON AN
INTERCOM FOR THE LA COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT SAY WE HAVE A THE
WOOZY FIRE JUST BROKE OUT AND
WE NEED FIFTY FIRE ENGINES
RIGHT NOW. ANY FIRED UP MEANT
COULD HEAR THAT. ANY FARBER
MAKE IT HERE THAT AND GO HEY
I'M SAN AND TO STRIKE TEAMS
RIGHT NOW. WE DO IT RIGHT NOW
FOR AIRCRAFT. LET'S DO IT FOR
FIRE ENGINES. AS MENTIONED-
IROC SYSTEM COMING ONLINE.
THERE'S OTHER SYSTEMS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT SUCH AS EN
MASSE AND AS CHIEF TYLER SAID
WHEN ROSS WAS PUT IN WE DIDN'T
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE. CAN I
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T HAVE THE
SEAT AT THE TABLE SO WE ARE
COMING TOGETHER RIGHT NOW TO.
WORK WITH CAL FIRE TO HELP
BUILD THAT CAPABILITY IN. AND
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT REAL TIME
INTELLIGENCE. REAL TIME
RESOURCES STATUS SAYING AVIELLE
WAS MENTIONED. EVERY YES FIRE
ENGINE AS A DEAL ON IT. SOME OF
THEM HAVE VERIZON ALL OF THEM
ARE BEING SWITCHED OUT TO
EIGHTEEN T. FIRST MET. AND I
CAN TELL YOU IS THE KERN COUNTY
FIRE CHIEF WE HAD EIGHTEEN T.
FIRST IN A IN KERN COUNTY BY
CHIEF OFFICER ADDED ON THEIR
PHONE. AND YES THE GOAL IS TO
GET A VIDEO ON EVERY FIRE
ENGINE IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
WORKING ON THAT AS WE SPEAK. AS
MENTIONED REASON. ROSS IS KIND
OF A- IT'S TIME IS THE PROCESS
WE CAN GIVE YOU A AN ANALOGY
IMAGINE YOU TOOK TWO FINALS AND
PUT THE SMALL ENDS TOGETHER.
ALL THE RESOURCE REQUEST GOING
IN ON TOP ANY GETS BOTTLE NECK
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE. AS IT GOES
OUT TO DIFFERENT FIRE
DEPARTMENTS FILL OUT ORDER AND
WHEN THE ORDERS ARE FILLED THE
<c.cyan>IRE ENGINES AND FIREFIGHTERS</c>
COME OUT OF THE BOTTOM THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE FACED WITH WITH ROSS.
WE'RE USING A PROGRAM RIGHT
NOW. THAT WE'RE IMPLEMENTING
ACROSS THE STATE. AND THE
BORDER DIRECTORS FOR FIRE
SCHOOL VOTED ON IT RECENTLY
IT'S A REAL TIME MAX FOUR OH
FIVE MAX STANDS FOR MULTI
AGENCY COORDINATION. FIRED
APART FOR PUTTING IN THEIR
AVAILABLE RESOURCES. AND THEY
MANAGE IT ON A DAILY BASIS AN
HOURLY BASIS. BY INCIDENT BASIS
SO WE KNOW FOR THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT SAID INSTITUTE THIS
PROGRAM. HOW MANY FIRE ENGINES
ARE AVAILABLE TO THE SYSTEM IN
ANY GIVEN TIME. THAT'S REAL
TIME SITUATIONAL AWARENESS. I
CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW WE ARE
WORKING ON A FIVE YEAR
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR CALLAWAY AS
FIRE AND RESCUE. WE DEFINITELY
NEED A PLAN GOING FORWARD TO
THE FUTURE. YOU CAN THROW ALL
THE MONEY THAT IS BUT IF WE
DON'T HAVE A PLAN ON HOW TO
EXECUTE WHAT THE PRIORITIES ARE
WE WILL FAIL. THIS PLAN SHOULD
BE A DOCUMENTED AND
IMPLEMENTATION BEGAN BY JULY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR. WE'RE ALSO
WORKING WITH CAL FIRE ON AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE SERVICE. WHERE ARE THE
FIRE ENGINES IN CALIFORNIA.
WHERE ARE THE FIRE STATIONS.
WHERE ARE THE OVER ONE THOUSAND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FIRE
DEPARTMENTS. THIS SURVEY IS
BEEN DEVELOPED AND SENT OUT TO
THE CALIFORNIA FIRES SERVICE
THEY'RE RETURNING THAT SURVEY.
AND WE WILL HAVE A GOOD
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IS
AVAILABLE TO THE MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM NOT ONLY FIRE ENGINES
BUT SPECIALIZE RESOURCES SUCH
AS URBAN SEARCH RESCUE AND HAS
MATT. WE'RE WORKING ON A JOINT
G. I. S. DATABASE. THAT WILL
ALLOW THE MANIPULATION OF DATA.
SO WE KNOW WHAT'S AVAILABLE.
WHERE IT'S AT AND THOSE WILL
ALLOW US TO MAKE DECISIONS ON
WHERE WE CAN DO IMPROVEMENTS AN
AUGMENTATION. TO BOLSTER THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE AND RESCUE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM. WE HAD A
PLAN THE PLAN STILL OF OURS
CALLED THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION IF YOU HAVEN'T READ
IT. I ENCOURAGE YOU TO READ IT.
IT WAS BORN OUT OF THOUSAND
THREE FIRES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE WORKING
THROUGH THE FIRES GO BOARD OF
THE DIRECTORS TO REVISIT THIS
VITAL REPORT ON THE CALIFORNIA
FIRES SERVICE. SOME THINGS A
BIT COMPLETED THERE'S A
RECOMMENDATION IN THERE FOR.
CALIFORNICA IT MORE HELICOPTERS
BETTER HELICOPTERS THAT
RECOMMENDATION IS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW LET'S SEE WHAT'S
VALID IN THERE LET'S SEE WHAT
WE NEED TO ADD BUT THIS IS A
GUIDING DOCUMENT AND WE AT- YES
ARE WORKING AGAIN TO THE FIRE
SCHOOL BOARD OF DIRECTORS TO
REACH THIS STUFF. YOU CANNOT BE
UNDERSTATED IMPORTANT
CALIFORNIA MUTUAL AID SYSTEM IS
IN PERFECT PREPARING FOR
RESPONDING TO AN RECEIVING. AND
RECOVERING FROM ALL FORMS A
NATURAL IN TECHNOLOGY-
TECHNOLOGICAL DISASTERS. MUTUAL
AID SYSTEM PROVIDED HELP TO THE
OROVILLE DAM WHEN WE HAD A
POTENTIAL FOR FAILURE. MUTUAL
AID SYSTEMS THERE TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN. THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING
ME AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
THESE COMMENTS AND ALL BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU IF YOU THOUGHT.
MEMBERS SHARE YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND HAVING SEEN THE
GREAT WORK THE CALLOW YES DOES
ON ON. COORDINATING AND HELPING
PARTICIPATE IN THESE EVENTS I
WANT TO THANK YOU DO HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS THOUGH. I
DIDN'T HEAR AN ANSWER TO THE
CONCERNS THAT THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM ON THIS MUTUAL AID IS
THAT INITIAL ASK. SO ARE ARE
YOU SUGGESTING THAT. THAT THE
LOCALS WILL BE OR SHOULD BE
CALLING- YES AND THAT YOU WILL
THEN. BY VIRTUE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY OR WHAT HAVE YOU BE
IDENTIFYING THOSE OTHER LOCAL
AGENCIES IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS
THAT SHOULD BE- SENDING
ASSISTANCE. OF BECAUSE I JUST
THE I KNOW WHAT YOU DO AND I
KNOW YOU DO A GREAT JOB BUT THE
FOCUS HERE FROM THE
CONVERSATION SAID I. WAS
HEARING EARLIER IS THAT. THOSE
INITIAL MOMENTS THOSE INITIAL
FIRST FEW HOURS. ARE WHERE THE
DELAY IS AND- THAT'S- ONE OF
THE AREAS WHERE WE NEED TO
CLOSE IT OUT. THE AYE THE- I. I
COAST WHATEVER THE AYE ROQUE
IROC SYSTEM- REPLACING THE ROSS
SYSTEM IS WHAT I GUESS WERE
HOPING IS GOING TO WORK BUT-
THAT'S THE SECOND PART OF MY
QUESTION SO IF YOU COULD ANSWER
THE FIRST PART. WHAT IS GOING
TO BE THE LAW THE ROLE OF- YES
IN TRYING TO REDUCE THAT TIME
FRAME AND GET THE RESOURCES
ALLOCATED FROM OTHER
JURISDICTIONS TO HELP LOCALS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. SO IN THE
CASE OF A WILDLAND FIRE IN THIS
IS JUST ONE FIRE THAT'S
OCCURRING IN THE STATE. THE
JURISDICTION BEGINS PLACING
ORDERS IN THE OPERATIONAL AREA
AND THOSE ARE TYPICALLY THE
COUNTY. ALTHOUGH WE HAVE
MULTIPLE OPERATIONAL AREAS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN REGION
ONE AND THEN THE TAHOE BASIN.
SO THE SYSTEM IS DESIGNED LOCAL
JURISDICTION TECH COUNTY WHICH
SYSTEM WE TALK ABOUT THE
PHARMACY MUTUAL AID SYSTEM TO
GET HELP THANK YOU SO YOU ORDER
OBVIOUSLY LOCAL JURISDICTION
HAS THE RESPONSIBILITY IF THAT
INCIDENT. EXCEEDS THEIR
CAPABILITY THEY'RE GOING TO
THEY'RE SURROUNDING FIRE
DEPARTMENTS FOR HELP RIGHT.
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE CLOSEST
AVAILABLE RESOURCE AS IT
CONTINUES TO ESCALATE THEY'RE
GOING TO THEIR LOCAL
OPERATIONAL AREA THAT COUNTY IF
YOU WILL FOR HELP AND RESOURCES
ARE COMING. AS THE INCIDENT EEK
SCAPES THAT INITIAL ATTACK AND
BECOMES LARGER WE GO TO THE
REGION THERE SIX REGIONS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THOSE CLOSE IS
RESOURCES BEGIN THE RESPONDED
INCIDENT. ONCE AT REGION IS
TAPPED OUT AND THERE'S NO MORE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE THEN IT
COMES TO THE STATE. AND WE
START. PUTTING RESOURCE REQUEST
TO OTHER REGIONS. OBVIOUSLY
AGAIN THE CLOSER THE RESOURCE
THE QUICKER THE RESPONSE SO WE
ARE TRYING TO MOVE RESOURCES
QUICKLY. IT ALL GOES INTO A
SYSTEM AS I MENTIONED THE FINAL
HE GETS INTO THAT MIDDLE OF THE
FINAL WORD THE WORD- IT SLOWS
DOWN. BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO GIVE
THAT INFORMATION TO A FIRE
DEPARTMENT YOU CALL UP THE LA
COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT YOU SAY
I NEED A STRIKE TEAM OF FIRE
ENGINES LA COUNTY MAY BE ABLE
TO FILL IT THEY MAY BE ABLE TO
FILL IT DEPENDING ON WHAT THE-
BUSINESS. AND THEIR FIRE. THIS
USING THIS LIVE FOUR OH FIVE
SYSTEM SO WE KNOW THAT LA
COUNTY DOESN'T HAVE A STRIKE
TEAM OF FIRE ENGINES AVAILABLE
RIGHT NOW. SO WE DON'T EVEN
HAVE TO GO TO LA COUNTY WE GO
RIGHT TELL THE CITY BECAUSE WE
KNOW THEY HAVE IT AVAILABLE. WE
YES SIR IS WE THE LOCALS IT'S
ANYBODY USING THE SYSTEM THIS
SYSTEM IS NOT OVER YES
PROPRIETARY IT'S FOR THE SYSTEM
SO THESE DISPATCH CENTERS. HAVE
A- THEY CAN LOOK ON IT AND THEY
KNOW WHAT'S AVAILABLE IN THEIR
SURROUNDING AREAS BECAUSE
THEY'RE PUTTING THEIR
INFORMATION AND ALSO. SO DOES
THAT CAN EXPLAIN HOW ORDERS
MOVE THROUGH THE SYSTEM WELL IS
THAT HOW THEY CURRENTLY DO
BECAUSE CLEARLY WHAT'S
CURRENTLY HAPPENING IS WORKING
TOO SLOWLY AT LEAST AS I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN EXPRESSED THAT. WHAT
THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS TOO SLOW
AND IT TO AND I KNOW THAT IN A
NUMBER OF FIRES IT'S TAKING WAY
TOO LONG FOR THE AID TO COME TO
THEM ONE SIX IT'S GREAT BUT
THAT THAT KEY CRITICAL. WE MALL
IS THE- SO BUILDING THE TELL
MOM IS ASIAN UNIT AT O. S. TO
TRY TO INCREASE THE STAFFING TO
HELP MOBILIZE RESOURCES.
BECAUSE STAFFING IN THE REGION
DISPATCH CENTERS AS WAS
MENTIONED. IS ONE OF THE ISSUES.
THIS VETS DISPATCH CENTERS ARE
STAFFED BASED ON WHAT THEIR
DAILY NEEDS ARE WHEN YOU HAVE A
WOODLEY FIRE THAT'S NOT THE
NORMAL STAFFING. THAT DISPATCH
CENTER THAT NEEDS TO BE THERE
SO WE'RE TRYING TO BOLSTER THAT
RIGHT NOW AND IN THE PROPOSED
BUDGET. TRANSACTION THAT THAT
WILL HELP GET MORE DISPATCHERS
TO HELP PROCESS ORDERS AND GET
THEM MOVING SO THIS ARE A
SYSTEM- I WAS VERY CONCERNED TO
HEAR THAT THERE'S BEEN NO.
TRAINING AT THIS POINT IN TIME
FOR LOCALS AND THAT THE SYSTEM
THERE'S GOING TO BE A WEEK GAPS
SO WE ALL HAVE TO HOPE AND PRAY
WE DON'T HAVE A MAJOR EVENT
DURING. WE EXPLAIN TO THE
PUBLIC. I GOT TO TELL YOU I AM.
REALLY CONCERNED. THAT NOW WE
KNOW. THAT THE AT LEAST IF THIS
IS ACCURATE THAT WOULD WE
HAVEN'T TRAINED ANY THE LOCALS.
ON THE USE OF THE SYSTEM. AND
THAT THERE'S A WEEK BETWEEN
WHEN THE ROSS SYSTEM IS CLOSED
IS TURNED OFF AND THE IRA AND
THE IRAQ SYSTEM. IS IN PLACE
COULD YOU PLEASE HELP. CLARIFY
THAT SITUATION I MEAN IT'S SO.
I KNOW THE FEDS OR SOMEONE
INVOLVED BUT- WE'RE IN THE
ETHER ARE THEY WITH YOU THEY'RE
NOT HERE AND I KNOW THE FEDS
HAVE BEEN HELPFUL BUT- THESE
ARE OUR FIRES WHO'S GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE HOW WE GOING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE SYSTEM IS
OPERATING THAT WE ARE HELP
THOSE PEOPLE IT THERE IS IN
FACT THE FIRE. THE SYSTEMS
NATIONAL AND FOR THAT ONE
BECAUSE OPERATIONAL WE HAVE
PEOPLE KNOW HOW TO USE IT.
THANK YOU MADAM I SHARE- SO-
CHIEF MARSHALL TALKED ABOUT THE
BROAD SPECTRUM OF HAVE AN ORDER
IS PLACED. SO LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE TRANSITION. FROM ROSS THE
IRAQ LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT GAP
FIRST. SO EVERY CENTER SHOULD
HAVE I WOULD HOPE WOULD HAVE A
CONTINUITY OF OPERATIONS PLAN.
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO OPERATE
THEIR NINE ONE ONE CENTER IF
THE POWER GOES OUT IF AN
EMERGENCY HAPPENS THEY SHOULD
HAVE A BACKUP PLAN. SO WHAT WE
WOULD HOPE IS THAT SPECIFIC TO
ROB US THAT EVERYBODY IS AWARE
FAMILIAR WITH AND EXERCISING
THEIR BACKUP PLAN HOW IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. FIRST FOREMOST
EVERY DISPATCH CENTER HAS A
COMPUTED IT COMPUTER AIDED
DISPATCH CENTER HAD HAD HS A
COMPUTER AIDED DISPATCH SYSTEM
A CAD SYSTEM IF YOU WILL.
THEY'RE ABLE TO DISPATCH THEIR
RESOURCES AND IN SOME INSTANCES
WHERE THOSE CATS SYSTEMS CAN
TALK TO EACH OTHER THEY CAN
TALK CROSS JURISDICTIONAL- AND
GO CAT THE CAT. OTHER TIMES
THEY CAN'T BUT SPECIFICALLY
WERE TALKING ABOUT ROSS SO
pIS LARGE ENOUGH THAT ROSS WOULD
HAVE BEEN NEEDED DURING THIS
BLACKOUT PERIOD YOU HAVE
DISPATCHER IN ORDER STE. DEAF
OR WISHING UNITS THAT WHO
ADDRESSING AND TRACKING THOSE
RESOURCES ON WHAT WE CALL ONE A
ONE CARDS ARE SOURCE ORDER
CARDS THEY CAN ALSO BE TRACKED
ON TWO CARDS. FROM THERE. THE
TELEPHONE OR RADIO IS WHAT'S
GOING TO BE. TO TALK THROUGH
THOSE OP AREAS TALK TO THE
DISPATCH CENTERS TO BE ABLE TO
TRACK THAT BLACKOUT PERIOD THAT
PERIOD OF SEVEN DAYS NOW WE
KNOW THAT AS I SAID NGUYEN THAT
IRAQ SYSTEM COMES UP SEVEN DAYS
LATER THERE WILL HAVE BEEN NO%
TRAINING SO FOR ME TO SAY THAT
THIS THIS CONTINUITY OF
OPERATION PLAN IS ONLY GOING TO
LAST FOR SEVEN DAYS IT WILL
LAST LONGER THAN SEVEN DAYS WHY
HAVEN'T PEOPLE BEEN TRAINED ON
THE- BECAUSE- FEDERAL. IS WHO
ARE PRIMARILY RESPONSIBLE. FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF IRAQ
WHICH BY THE WAY IS A FREE
SYSTEM TO CALIFORNIA- HAVE NOT
FULLY IMPLEMENTED. ALL OF THE
TRAINING COMPONENTS THAT THEY
ARE ACTIVELY WORKING ON WE'RE
ACTIVELY SPEAKING WITH OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS EXPRESSING THE
SAME CONCERNS THAT YOU'RE
EXPRESSING TODAY. WELL I DON'T
KNOW IF THIS IS ANOTHER ONE OF
MR TRUMP'S EFFORTS TO GET BACK
IN CALIFORNIA BUT I JUST HOPE
WE DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM DURING
THAT PERIOD OF TIME OR
SUBSEQUENTLY THERE TOO SO- I
IT'S MY HOPE AND IF THERE'S
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO HELP
EXPEDITE THAT BUT THIS IS. OF
CONCERN IF WE IF WE'RE GOING TO
BE DOWN AND WE'RE GOING BACK TO
SORT OF THE OLD WAY OF DOING
THINGS YOU KNOW. THE CHURCH
BELLS RINGING WHEN THERE'S AN
EMERGENCY. AND AS HAS BEEN
POINTED OUT. YOUR YOUR YOR CAR
WILL TELL YOU WHERE YOUR
NEAREST STARBUCKS IS. BECAUSE
WE ARE TRACKED. BY AND OVER-
AGAIN- EXPERTS EXAMINED- BY
TECHNOLOGY AND YET WE ARE GOING
TO HAVE A SYSTEM UP THAT'S
GOING TO HELP FACILITATE AND
EXPEDITE. IN CASE OF EMERGENCY
BECAUSE THE FEDS HAVEN'T
COMPLETED THEIR- ROLE LIVE
CHAT- DEBTS. WHICH IS KIND OF
EMBARRASSING. AB OF PERHAPS I'M
NOT SAYING TO THE STATE BUT-
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT SHOULD
SHOULD NOT BE THE CASE AND- IF
PERHAPS WE CAN HAVE SOME
OFFLINE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
WHAT WE WANTED TO AYE I'D
CERTAINLY. BE DELIGHTED OR WE
CAN SEND MY COLLEAGUE HERE TO
RAISE HOLY HELL. IN CONGRESS
AND WITH THAT I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TEST. SENATOR DID
YOU HAVE ANYTHING ANY QUESTIONS
SENATOR GALGIANI. OUR GERMAN
THANK YOU I HAVE ACTUALLY A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS- FIRST OF
ALL IN AND I THINK THEY GO MORE
TO JUST- DATA AND QUESTIONS ON
ON SOME OF THE NUMBERS YOU
PRESENT IT'S I WAS VERY PLEASED
TO HEAR THAT THERE IS A PLAN TO
ADD STOPPING IN THE NUMBER OF
SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN.
ADDITIONAL MANPOWER RESOURCES-
I'M ASSUMING THOUGH THAT CAN BE
ACCOMMODATED IN THE TRAINING
PLAN THAT THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
OUTSIDE OF THAT AND WHAT THAT
DEPLOYMENT LOOKS LIKE YOU KNOW
FIVE YEARS OUT WHICH IS STILL
YOU KNOW FIVE YEARS AND FIRE
TERMS NOW WE KNOW THAT'S- WHAT
ACRES. UP I HAVE. BEEN DONE.
STATEWIDE TO AT LEAST TRY TO
FIGURE OUT A NUMBER OF WHAT
THAT STAFFING. NEED WOULD LOOK
LIKE IF WE WERE ADDRESSING. MAN
HOURS AS THEY'VE BEEN ROLLED
OUT OVER THESE LAST SEVERAL
FIRE YEARS IT FOR INSTANCE IN
AN IDEAL NUMBER. WOULD BE SIX
SEVENTY SEVEN A GOOD STARTING
PLACE BUT WE GOT TO NINE
HUNDRED WE'D REALLY BE MEETING
WHAT WE KNOW IS AN UNMET NEED
BECAUSE THAT KIND OF
CALCULATION BEEN MADE. SO I
WANT TO BE. CLEAR THANK YOU
ASKING A QUESTION. THAT NUMBER
REFERRING TO A SPECIFICALLY TO
CAL FIRE. SUPPORT BOTH. IN THE
CHIEF HERE HEAD. JUST ABOUT
HELLFIRE IT'S ABOUT SO THE
ENTIRE FIRE SERVICE PROGRAM
ACROSS THE CALIFORNIA SO
SPECIFIC TO CAL FIRE- WE HAVE
STAFFING ALLOCATION GUIDELINES-
TO MEET OUR NEEDS- THE STAFF
BEHIND ME THAT ARE HERE TO
SUPPORT TODAY- HAVE USED
METHODOLOGY IS TURMAN WHEN YOU
LOOK AT- SICK LEAVE YOU LOOK AT
WORKERS COMPENSATION YOU LOOK A
VACATION YOU LOOK AT- HOLIDAYS
THOSE TYPES OF. METHODS IT
BRINGS US TO A POINT OF THE
ADDITIONAL STAFFING WE NEED TO
SUPPORT OUR CURRENT- FIRE%
ENGINE- HELLO ATTACK IN
AIRCRAFT CAPABILITIES- LOOKING
INTO AN ANALYSIS AND ALICE'S
DEEPER OF WHAT WE COULD NEED
FIVE YEARS FROM NOW. OR LOOKING
AT THE PAST SIX YEARS- WE WOULD
NEED TO TAKE A DEEPER DIVE INTO
THAT- AND I THINK THAT LOOKING
AT THE NEEDS ASSESSMENT ACROSS
THE ENTIRE CITY CALIFORNIA. WE
CAN DO THAT AS WELL. YEAH A
GREAT I THINK THAT'S A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT WE NEED TO START
HAVING THAT NUMBER IN OUR HEAD
WHEN WE CONCEPTUALIZE THAT WHEN
WE'RE IN. BUDGET YOU'RE SEEN
FOR THE LAST COUPLE YEARS WHERE
WE- STAY BUDGET WE BASS.
DEPLOYED MAKE SURE THE WERE
WERE MATCHING. NEED AND THEN
CHIEF TO YOUR POINT APPRECIATE
A COUPLE THINGS THAT YOU SAID
FIRST F ALL- OUR MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM IS TO ADDRESS ALL
HAZARDS IN A QUESTION THAT
COMES UP TO ME ALL THE TIME IS.
YOU KNOW. FOR LACK OF YOU KNOW
WE DON'T WE DON'T WANNA BE-
CRISIS AT. GET INTO TO HAVE OUR
CRISES BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA OBVIOUSLY ARE
CONCERNED ALWAYS ABOUT- WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF AN EARTHQUAKE
HITS. AND WE ALSO A MAJOR FIRE
EVENTS GOING ON IN THE STATE AT
THE SAME TIME- SOUNDS LIKE YOU
GUYS HAVE OBVIOUSLY GIVEN A LOT
OF THOUGHT TO THAT THE
DEPLOYMENT AYE I WATCHED YOU
KNOW FROM AFAR FOR THE
RIDGECREST I THOUGHT IT WAS A
PRETTY REMARKABLE DEPLOYMENT-
BUT PERHAPS IF YOU COULD SPEAK
TO THAT A LITTLE BIT WHAT PART
OF THE FIVE YEAR STRATEGIC
PLANNING- ARE YOU GUYS GIVING
BACK CONSIDERATION TO NOW THAT
WE KNOW FIRE SEASON. AROUND WE
ALSO A QUICK AS A YEAR RISK A-
MERRY THE- TWO CONCERNS I THEN
SECONDARY TALKED ABOUT. THE NEW
ENGINES COMING ONLINE WHICH I
FIND REALLY HEARTENING THAT'S
GREAT WITH THE YOU KNOW EARLIER
PANEL SPOKE TO THE NEED FOR
ENGINES. WHAT DOES THAT LOOK
LIKE IN TERMS OF A REGIONAL.
DEPLOYMENT OF THOSE RESOURCES
WHERE PERHAPS THAT TRAVEL TIME
THAT RESPONSE TIME. IS
RESOURCES ACTUALLY DELIVERED TO
US. SO LET ME TAKE THAT
QUESTION FOR SO WE ARE OUT
RIGHT NOW WORKING WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FIRE DEPARTMENTS-
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. TO
BECOME AN ASSIGNEE OF THOSE
FIRE APPARATUS. WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT WHAT THE GAPS ARE IN
COVERAGE. AND WHO CAN SUPPORT-
THE STRIKE TEAMS AT THESE FIRE
ENGINES SO I RECEIVED A PHONE
CALL FROM A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEF AND HIS OPERATIONAL
AREA ONCE FIVE OF THESE FIRE
ENGINES SO IT'S IN A GOOD. TEN
AREA AS FIRES IN A IN AN AREA
THAT YOU WOULD A RESPONDED TO
THE WAS THE FIRE IF THEY WOULD
HAVE BEEN THERE SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT GAPS IN WHO CAN
SUPPORT. ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
IS STAFFING IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA- YEAH YOU CAN PUT
ALL THE FIRE TRUCKS IN THE
WORLD YOU WANT OR YOU CAN. BUT
HAVING THE STAFFING TO SEND
THOSE FIRE TRUCKS OUT THE DOOR
WHEN THE NEED IS THERE IS
SOMEWHAT OF A CHALLENGE
STAFFING IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE
THE CHALLENGE. SO WE'RE LOOKING
AT A GAP ANALYSIS AND WE'LL GET
THOSE FIRE ENGINES OUT. THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE IN
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKES FLOODS
FIRES. NOT JUST WILDLAND FIRES
BUT YOU KNOW SOMETHING- SUCH AS
A REFINERY FIRE THOSE YOU KNOW.
THOSE EVENTS SAID END UP ON THE
FRONT PAGE OF THE NEWSPAPER AND
THE LEAD STORY ON THE NEWS
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO BE READY
FOR AND THE STRATEGIC PLAN FOR
YES FIRE AND RESCUE WE'RE
LOOKING AT WERE THOSE GAPS ARE
AND HOW WE CAN MAKE THINGS
BETTER. UP IN THE URBAN SURGERY
Q. SYSTEM WE HAVE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS OF IT WE
USED A LOT OF THOSE COMPONENTS
IN. RIDGECREST BUT LET'S SAY WE
HAVE THE BIG EARTHQUAKE SEVEN
CALIFORNIA THE BAY AREA WE'RE
GOING TO BE GETTING HELP FROM
MAYBE INTERNATIONAL. HAVING A
SEAMLESS PROGRAM FOR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE BECAUSE OF I'VE SAID
DURING MY CAREER AS A AS A FIRE
CHIEF FOR KERN COUNTY AND AS I
SAY NOW. THERE'S SMOKE IN THE
AIR IT'S TOO LATE. GOT TO HAVE
THOSE PLANS SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE WORKING AND WE'RE
COLLABORATING THE FIRE SCOPE
BORDER DIRECTORS AND THE AND
THE GROUPS THAT WORK UNDER
THAT. REALLY PROVIDE THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FIRE
SERVICE LEADERS AND BEING ABLE
TO DEVELOP PLANS AND- AND
TECHNOLOGIES AND GET THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE SERVICE AGAIN
JUST SCHEME WAS. WE'VE GOT A
GOOD SYSTEM LET'S JUST MAKE IT
BETTER. THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY APPRECIATED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AT THIS POINT I'D
LIKE TO OPEN IT UP TO- PUBLIC
COMMENT ANYONE HAS ANYTHING. TO
ADD TODAY'S HEARING. GOING ONCE.
ALL RIGHT WELL SEEING NO PUBLIC
COMMENT AGAIN I'M I THANK
EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION TODAY LOOK
FORWARD WILL DO A WRAP UP
REPORT ON OUR END BUT YOUR
INSIGHTS HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION THANK YOU SO
MUCH.